oh
[Applause]
[Music]
oh
[Music]
then
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
the world is
[Music]
get them out of your way
don't melt in the world find you a way
[Music]
[Music]
you
are
not alone
[Music]
we'll build the sky
[Applause]
i'll take them away
[Music]
[Music]
don't melt in the world find you our way
[Music]
[Music]
get them out of your way
[Music]
listen to your heart that's the voice in
yourself
[Music]
in the world
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
countless foods
[Music]
sleep
[Music]
don't cry
fingers
[Music]
one more round
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
enough to
[Music]
seem to be
blessing us
[Music]
what's going on
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
is
[Music]
keep trying to
[Music]
oh
[Applause]
[Music]
i was born
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
okay
is
[Music]
is
[Music]
[Music]
if
[Music]
is
[Music]
don't be curious about me
i don't want you to get hurt
watch
out don't make a big deal
[Music]
nevermind
splash
[Music]
[Music]
okay
is
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
i don't want you to get hurt
watch out keep your hands up don't make
a big deal
[Music]
[Music]
again
[Music]
[Music]
i'm a terrible liar
forgive me that's not the
[Music]
keep
article
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
those who dream of heaven
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
keep crying
[Music]
that's is i have to go
[Music]
[Music]
oh
[Music]
[Music]
history
[Music]
bringing all your bosses
[Music]
oh
[Applause]
[Music]
down
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
hey
she told me
[Music]
how do we
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
up
[Music]
[Music]
oh
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
oh
[Music]
[Music]
today
[Music]
i feel like
[Music]
[Music]
uh
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
are you into fighting games then guilty
gear strive is definitely your jam
this is truly a next level fighting game
experience a cut above the most popular
franchises the guilty gear series has
earned its cult classic status for so
many reasons such as its deep technical
gameplay and stunning art style this is
as good as it gets in the fighting game
world 600 of the best players in north
america have been competing in the epic
arc revo america tournament for guilty
gear strive and the remaining qualifying
players are going to face off against
each other in the finals at the esports
engine studio in sunny southern
california for 30 thousand dollars in
prize money it's gonna be an amazing
showcase for guilty gear strive with
masters of the game showing off their
best combos mix-ups and footsies it'll
be an experience players have been
fighting for over the past year and now
it's time to see who's the best of the
best if you've always wanted to try
guilty gear but worried it might be too
complicated for you now is the best time
ever to dip your toe in the water the
latest game guilty gear strive is the
most approachable in the series with its
easy to get into but difficult to master
approach yes it's gonna take many hours
in the lab with no shortage of ls on the
way to compete with the best guilty gear
stride is as brainy as it is beautiful
but nothing feels better than playing as
mei and slapping your opponents with a
big anchor not to mention uh nailing
them in the face with sea animals and
look at that art style guilty gear's
signature 2d 3d hybrid shaded cell
animation is unrivaled just look at it i
mean come on this is the rare fighting
game that has a real story that's
actually good if you like dope fighting
games and dope anime well you can get
both of those things from guilty gear
strive and on top of that guilty gear
strive has got an incredible roster of
characters each with their own unique
movesets here's the time traveling
martial artist axel lowe demolishing
fools with his dual sickles
guilty gear community staple and arc
revo finalist flash metroid likes using
him
and check out beefcake one shot artist
nagoriyuki a vampire samurai with a
magic katana that arc revo finalist
tatashi prefers
and let's not forget the blind assassin
zado and his insanely cool ghost buddy
you like that don't you there's going to
be plenty of that and so much more at
the arc revo finals you don't have to be
a guilty gear fan or even be that into
fighting games to appreciate a great
player doing awesome stuff and looking
extremely sick doing it in one of the
most gorgeous video games around and arc
revo is gonna have as much of that as
you can take it's gonna be spectacular
and it's for a good cause during arc
revlo they've raised more than twenty
thousand dollars for the child's play
charity which provides video game
consoles games and toys to kids give
those kids games guilty gear and arc
revo really have something for everyone
and the arc revo finals with prizes from
hitbox and astro gaming will be an
absolute blast for fans and newcomers
alike but the spectacle doesn't end
after a champion is crowned because
developer arc system works has a huge
announcement about the future of guilty
gear stride at the end of the finals so
if you are into guilty gear strive be
sure to watch to the very end for a
major treat
there's something inside of everyone
a drive
for greatness
for victory
some never pursue this drive
others let greatness slip through their
fingers
but some
will keep fighting
pushing themselves to the limit
[Music]
to the
[Music]
extreme the chance
at glory
out of over 600 players only six
fighters will continue to the
championship round
until one remains
each of them have it
the drive
[Music]
or greatness
[Music]
but will it be enough to carry them to
victory
only one way to find out
[Music]
[Music]
you
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
moisten up giovanna with the blood you
feel me you'll see how much he's willing
to sacrifice to get in quick because
that's one of the hallmarks of watashi's
gameplay right is that he's very
aggressive about the gate he's looking
to overwhelm his opponent he's not
afraid to pop that blood max because a
lot of the time he has setups where it
actually pops on hit right so it knocks
down the opponent in the corner makes
them guess between a throw or a high or
some type of game like that and yeah
we're getting into it right now both
players taking a moment
baby because this is finals don't get it
twisted we ain't got nowhere to go after
this yeah exactly and you know speaking
about these players you know right now i
mean obviously current reigning evil
online guilty gear north america
champion hotashi but you know through
all the weeklies that we've been having
there's so many guilty gear events
kotashi
i you know
i don't know if it's even a debate i
feel like he's positioned himself as the
best in the na region right now
very strong
and uh however in the series e event
days and hotashi played each other one
time days did win that one
and then he had to dequeue himself to
the tournament but you know
doing some research on these two it
seems like overall results are about 50
50 but davis has actually won the last
few sets
if my research is correct of course now
i got hot she already bullying updates
in the corner yeah
yeah exactly but you know the key thing
right now is that hitachi is so good at
frame trapping people especially with
that close and such and so days has
really have to find the time for the
right buttons but you can see here look
at this he's gotten the counter hits
he's got the escape he's got the wall
break this should do it
and round one two days so one thing when
i researched these players this specific
matchup is really good at pulling up
potashi's delay buttons on the defense
and you just saw it right there as well
with that 5h in the end yeah you know
plus frames on that drill attack right
there and
look at that just like the spacing to
get that heavy kick in there but now
here comes kotashi oh oh this is gonna
hurt
yeah we talked about him not being
afraid to sacrifice the life but he's
sacrificing much more than he planned to
yeah
did he get the mv perhaps got the yrc
though so now here comes the momentum
for a hotel
and hitachi has made so many comebacks
in fact
yeah man this is the start of another
one right
oh it wasn't enough to kill it wasn't
enough to kill him he's still alive oh
but the check on the ford fukio again
that's the second time i think we saw
that and two rounds and game number one
today's that's how you know the gore
you'd be good though bro how did he
survive that
i can't believe he actually lived
through the otg but wait a minute hit
blade blade at the round you might as
well just
yeah bad burst right there for days so
now you can see
completely empty burst meter if you
actually hit the burst you get some of
it back but look at this five minutes
time for the counter hits again i love
that dp kick and then you get another
chase in the back dash right we know
that
players love their back dash got an
extra frame available with the big
bodies and they do it all day every day
days exposing it yeah days again looking
very strong trying to go three rounds in
a row hotashi with a hero burst but it's
not gonna pay off he's gonna come to the
next round with no burst indeed i'm not
looking good at ultra academy with that
one friend oh 2d mode of the may blade
this time yeah uh we call that the [ __ ]
it's the 2d god man
oh and she really be representing that
she's the forgotten god of the 2ds oh
man and now look at this dash of throw
days the pressure what again just
waiting for the back dash get in with
the clothes test you'll be able to break
the wall that's plus frames on the stage
change it's not looking good for otashi
back dash does get him out of dodge for
now and the counter hit shizu okay this
is the cat i mean look nago dishes out
the damage we know what this character
can do and here we go this is going to
catch up in life but more importantly
we're gonna give him the positive meter
bonus however days has the meter for a
brc right after this let's see if that's
the option he goes with he's got a
hundred percent attention here i was
gonna say wake up super into the rc yeah
let's have it to keep it safe does so
here aren't you trying to check the blow
ooh even blocking the cross out of good
stuff
she needs to get around on the board but
there it is the 2d god
again
looking good here too and you know a lot
of the time i feel like it's a bit scary
for do you want to use that but winning
the gory yuki's in 2s range just because
nagoya's love that blend so much and
it's pretty good at being 2d to the
punch however he's just been finding
every single perfect timing of it we've
seen encounter hit beyblade we've seen
encounter hit buttons and i mean this is
looking great for days to start yeah and
keep in mind again these groups are
round robin so even though if hotashi
loses this if you could win the next
game and get one and one you know the
the goal is to hopefully have the third
player go 0 and 2 but no guarantees
there obviously a lot of potential for
thai scores here
let's see how this goes but hotasi wants
to get this win on the board like i said
positioned himself as probably the best
in the n a but days
definitely
oh fact that she was old this time too
you saw it
with the back dash right there
thought he had conditioned him enough to
sit there and block but no sir then this
time another counter here on the 2s this
is so surprising to me you rarely seen
the gory yuki's get their primary button
shut down like this
bright dance fighting is that a knock oh
my god even on nagoro
oh yeah this character has so much
defense so much guts and still enough
damage from giovanna
look at that 5 8 whistle too that's one
of the things about giovanna in this
matchup see it's just an easier time
closing the distance after easy whiff
now trapped in the corner here but
wow that first hit really far
and they still have the pressure catches
with the tv here we go going to get the
ball flat i'm gonna go for the super
wall break
just to get the hard knock down and the
pressure afterwards here we go just
needs this one round that's why hitachi
bursting up trying not to lose that last
heart
doesn't want to start this tournament
3-0 for sure
actually doesn't have enough blood yeah
but two and a half bars so that means
the two went to the five connects but
it's
america 3-0
why are people not using giovanna as
much anymore
character is so good
is hotashi and he is very upset about
the days getting the w right now over
the three over there john back and forth
a little bit all in good fun days man
what a way to start this off coming out
on fire i mean like i said i saw them
fight just the one time before and days
took that one and look at this showing
that he i mean he's it looks like he
studied this nagoroyuki match so
well
he had the whiff punish on the far s and
wow just really really came in here
prepared 100 right and going into this i
did my research on them in tournament
before and it seemed 50 50 until
recently they said really starting to
run away it's 50 50 because hotashi was
favored at the beginning and now days
has gotten three or four sets on them
straight so definitely very impressive
today's has really figured out what to
do in that matchup and yeah you see the
promise of giovanna i don't know why
people like playing there
so i know people are playing her now but
yeah good stuff once again today's look
at this just shutting down so many
options of nagoro yuki i thought he
called out the fuzzy timings on hotashi
perfectly so many times he got the
counter hit on the delayed buttons we
saw him he played good defense up
against the gorilla he as well really
prioritizing the fd in the corner just
overall textbook style i mean you saw
for example hitachi went for the command
throw and days back past that and then
hitachi backdash but daze called that
out and hit that he just had such a read
on what it was that i think this is the
the far slash whip no the whip punish oh
there was the 2d you know
yeah
he had a couple instances too where like
one time after beyblade from a little
bit of a distance away he did dp which i
thought was so smart because the dp
kicks it's only upper body interval
right it's not a true dp but if it
trades with like 5k from the gory that's
a huge straight for giovanna yeah that's
one of her best combo starters so i
really like to agree with that idea as
well yeah and like i said just i think
i i just wanted to see that that far
slash with punish because it was so good
i think it comes right
oh a far ahead of me that he would
punish right there it was so good and
like i said you know
the gory uk obviously when he gets that
blood gauge up the far slash the fire
heavy slash
practically like 75 of the screen
distance right there and to be able to
be aware that you can whip punish that
leaves the hurt box behind just really
nicely done in days starting off strong
indeed let's take a look at the
standings actually after that first
match just to make sure we get everybody
into the flow of things again this is
going to be a round robin format so days
starting off a nice and hot 1-0 here
hotashi following 0-1-1 here right so
hitachi's actually going to be our next
match as well so this is a very very
important set for him straight yeah
because i mean going down o2 is gonna be
real rough at that point yeah i think if
he goes down o2 that's it right because
then the other two players will be one
and oh so they're one of them's
guaranteed to be two oh the other one's
one one it would essentially yeah let's
say dave wins all of his matches and
then i think we would go to the
tiebreaker which would be like two one
twos versus each other whoever won that
match but we'll get to that if it
happens of course yeah so hotashi's
gonna be sitting down but before we get
to any of that we talked about the
prizes that they're gonna be winning the
prize pools and all that but y'all could
be winning surprises in the chat as well
via astro giving away those a40 headsets
you don't have any chaos being bumping
the tools you can do it just like happy
chaos by entering the giveaways in the
chats as we go to break
absolutely so don't go anywhere again it
is going to be a hotashi going up
against symbolist coming up next after
this
[Music]
what's going on
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
oh
[Music]
okay
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
my choices
[Music]
uh
[Music]
is
i don't want you to get hurt
watch out
[Music]
nevermind
[Music]
[Music]
oh
okay
is
tell me
come back
keep your hands up
[Music]
is
[Music]
to me
forgive me
[Music]
oh
[Music]
hey yo
shout outs to all my bad guys out there
of course and look at that beautiful
trophy the artwork of america champion
going home with that gonna be able to
add it to their collection that's a nice
show and i know i've talked to a lot of
players man you would be surprised about
how much medals and trophies really mean
a lot to them yeah and so a sick trophy
like that they're gonna be playing extra
hard today best believe yeah and so you
know if that trophy and myself happen to
disappear halfway through this broadcast
i it's weird i don't know it's
unexplainable i don't know yeah
just make sure you break off the soul
joint for me okay okay yeah there you go
there you go
i don't know what are you talking about
we've got a match coming up here
it's of course we're continuing with
group a and it is going to be symbolis
now going up against hotashi and uh
symbolist you know you see the soul bad
guy here on the screen but obviously
symbolist has a happy chaos as well
indeed i'm glad you brought that up
because the last time i saw similar's
play against the nagor yuki was test
your luck at wednesday night fights
earlier this month it was a very recent
set and it actually started with
symbolism on happy chaos going down 02
very quickly and then running it three
games straight back on the soul bad guy
oh dang so i'm expecting tony montana
i'm expecting scarface but we'll see if
he brings out the happy chaos first
happy chaos just one of those characters
that you have to have so it's he's kind
of like the new zotto right like if you
don't know how he works exactly yeah
you're done like you have to have the
knowledge to be able to fight this
character and watch their resources
notice when happy chaos runs out of
bullets like watching the eddie gauge
you know etc etc so uh obviously hitachi
probably has a lot of experience
fighting against happy chaos so we'll
see how this goes but i mean here on the
west coast uh happy chaos player umi
show has been kind of wrecking shop out
here right yeah yeah um definitely been
giving them plenty of practice in the
happy chaos matchup so we're going to
see how that translates to now we've
already seen my manhole tashi os on
twitter is he going to have to
continue or will he be a little bit more
comfortable we saw see okay well we
talked all about the happy chaos but it
is indeed gonna be the sole bad guy for
symbolists coming here and again you
know a lot of people have been talking
about nagoroyuki as the strongest
character right now you know oh my gosh
his character you know so strong so but
you know i mean seoul he was the
original problem when the game dropped
you know a lot of people theorize that
happy chaos is a pretty tough matchup
for nigeria
and but once he does happy chaos
we're invincible reversal whether you
got neither
that i think siblings feels more
comfortable
it's funny because like giovanna is not
necessarily known as a character with
long range
beyblade
you know uh the risk age was building up
early on
from satoshi at about two a little over
two in the blood gauge now that's one
thing i'm so glad that he already showed
that symbolism is very proficient at
instantly blocking the second hit of the
fought sequence of against
something to keep in mind going forward
on the other side hitachi very good at
instant blocking five eight blocks
the stop sign that two has oh but he is
even better at that he constantly looks
for those clashes with 5h and dp and he
nitrates after he's so ready with that
yeah unfortunately dropped the combo
afterwards potassium using the prc to
try to keep the pressure in the corner
right now
yeah he uses the field to try to get in
there he's trying to keep himself at
above
two bars of the blood gauge so he still
has access to that far 5h
and the brc to get in there this is the
throb against the air throw back in the
corner where are you going
you see that's what's so good about that
brc in the corner though that even
though he jumped and of course just gets
caught flinching right on the beyblade
maybe not emptying for the chip or
either way gets clipped and hitachi
taking the game one advantage yeah but
you know you were mentioning that brc
yes because it hits the opponent and so
even though they jump away from the
throne they're so
slowed down
right he's really
not only similar to the start that he
wants yeah both players already using
their verse right away
probably figured you know keep the
resources even at this point you should
have jumped up to changes jump our
timing yeah watashi is so good at that
honestly it actually kissed him at the
end a little otg cop alright i know
about that one most people are not
expecting the third swing of the sss
gatling but of course you know that's
why you get frame trap because you think
he's gonna stop oh he just slices about
the air and that's one of his whole
symbolism's primary ways of getting out
of that corner he loves the instant air
dash and it's very good up against the
goryugi because he's got these long
committal buttons right there hitachi
light and wait oh there was that id
second hit
press the 5k i don't know if that
actually went to the farthest sequence
but either way hotel of course still has
that three frame kick oh here we go nice
goes for the hard knock down on the now
probably going to send him through the
wall to kill him oh sir okay again you
see the instant block right there and i
like that it just moved from otoshi he
went with a special cancel instantly but
siblings was ready with the dp that was
really impressive yeah you see that one
situation coming up and the mind games
developing off of it we'll see how it
advances forward but oh what a clutch
back dash there but again hotashi
bursting to keep this man in the corner
trying to keep that momentum in his
corner
yeah symbolism
always do so much damage what is that
ot26h always hurts so much oh speaking
of ips nice id by a hotel there that's
what we're talking about right the
five-page should definitely get instant
blocked when soldiers kind of autopilot
that in a block street
damage all over the place
i'm really scared oh this is the opening
he might need here we go yeah i know rc
to extend it but the back dash gets
pumped again natasha relying on it a
little bit too much so the gorillas love
their back dash that's hidden
through the wall how are we going to
present this opportunity 100 meter on
the side of hotashi you got to respect
the 100
with the wake up super going up two to
zero and we had mentioned this is really
really important here he wants to end
this at one one to kill
he stays in there and then
the interesting part now is that hitachi
is gonna want to have uh days win the
next match so it'll be a 201
0-2 if potash
again only
but especially in the close slash it's
like a giant wall of hurt hitbox
basically
it's out of the air oh oh oh oh
and that's why we can extend the combo
to make sure it kills
at the beginning when the blood popped i
was like he could die for this as simple
as that's the right combo most
definitely and that's one thing that's a
hallmark of his game as well symbolism
has amazing conversions
here we go
oh not no wall splat on there just goes
up for the throw again this is
oh throw the reversal dp get that out of
here you just keep doing it only try for
one more finally the 5k brings him out
of it
oh baits it out but you know it was
blocked so he could still rc it and now
symbolism has the corner but a nice back
dash
from hotashi into a back fukio and just
kind of gave symbolis enough rope to try
to do something but ended up hanging
himself
beautiful success right there from
siblings and we talked about these
conversions look at it all the way in
the corner and where you'd be eating
this damage back dash getting clipped
to just kind of get himself out of the
corner it was only a it was a level zero
uh 5h as well
you can see symbol is still prioritizing
really approaching the variability on
the ground gets caught slipping there
there's a bit of an otg here so i'm not
sure how much of that 4s sequence was
actually going to connect but either way
symbolist was going to burst he had
already determined to burst we didn't
know that hitachi was going to drop it
oh he's going to be able to hit him
before that move attacks yeah oh but
here we go gets the kind of hit the prc
oh i thought he rc debate that burst but
he ends up getting clipped by it hotashi
still very much in this round and very
much in this set
oh and those ivs giving himself keeping
himself enraged here we go the back dash
with the far slash no three o's here
cymbel is getting one on the board and
we talked about that happy chaos but
he's on his last game right now it is
going to be soul bad guy and soul bad
guy alone here we go the successes are
working out a little bit better now i'm
liking the symbolism game a little bit
he seems to be getting a more
comfortable willing to be aggressive
over right now stuck in this corner
burst out on the fukio forward and this
is decent because otashi he can't really
use a special at this point he's got too
much blood
just trying to find the moment to get in
there trying to see if he can get
hitachi to whiff so he can run in
afterwards we've seen symbolists do that
a couple of times
wow
after that was so good
away he's just like no you're gonna hit
a button and i'm gonna dp it thank you
all the beers is out of it but again
like you're saying the slowdown on the
brc makes it harder to punish those
things no
did not convert that corner combo gets
cut out of the air
yeah it wasn't that bad for siblings
and clutch back dashes trying to make
the versus the vrc there committed to it
good patience for motashi and the throat
puts him on setpoint yet again
here we go
symbolists needing to take two rounds in
a row now to stay alive otashi just
needs to get this one round again those
ivs but that's why he goes with the
beyblade this time yes i love that
cancel interrupting the ib new symbols
we're trying to challenge after look how
much you pay for that
where where
oh god in his pocket
that's
you got all that meter now
oh yeah brc get out of there air block
you see consistently instant blocking
these uh second hits of the far s but at
this point he doesn't want to swing
after because of the beyblade counter
hitting him last time
oh perfectly time fukio forwarded to
grab as simple as we talked about that
right he likes to take to the skies a
little bit in the corner trying to make
his way out right there hotashi lying
away fukio forward as he lands to get
the throw and that's gotta give him a
little bit more of a reprieve you know
sanctuary so to speak yeah i mean
we we didn't get to see it on stream but
as soon as it ended like you could see
hitachi like sigh of relief and kind of
like a little mini celebration there but
of course he knows it's not quite over
yet but uh again interesting situation
now hitachi is 1-1
and uh days is 1-0 yeah and now symbolis
is 0-1 so if symbols could beat days
it's 1-1 across the board that's true
yeah we're going to figure out what
happens with that when we get to it of
course but big ups to hotashi keeping it
very interesting here in this group
stage but of course right now i believe
we i want to mention the replays because
that's what is going down
the gory yuki had really been running
rough shot over so bad guy a lot of time
in this cetera we got in the corner and
he had just been so good at yeah
delaying some of these beyblades really
managing his blood so he didn't pop
often you can see symbols just yeah i
felt like he didn't have the right bets
whether it be fd on the ground or he
wasn't really willing to do a lot of
ieds out of the corner even though he
did get caught jumping a couple of times
so
back in the corner so important and
again you know one of the hotachi's
biggest strengths is just the lead on
the opponent when he gets up close like
you can see this pressure right now look
at this
and then he finally gets the hit there
the counter hit on the wrist gauge and
then kept him from getting out of the
corner with the 6-8
yeah really really good just i think a
play from both sides honestly it was
just one of those situations where
potashi ended up winning the gambits
early and just kind of rode that to
and victory just really love it you know
we talked about how this is offline
right this is most definitely offline
and despite this game having a fantastic
netcode there are still very strict
execution things in this game like
instant blocking you only have a two
frame window so i love seeing how
consistent these fellows are at instant
blocking offline because it is not an
easy thing to do yeah you can see after
the wall break the little mini game that
shows up after the wall break is so key
and you know you were talking about the
fact that potassium had the full 100 bar
you caught hotashi called it out when
days had the 100 bar he knew he was
gonna wake up with the super in the rc
and there you saw symbolists did not
count on that from
just maybe hoping he would miss time to
wake up or something yeah it's like when
it comes to that and you look at the
risk reward of everything hotashi's not
knocking a super right because he wins
the game he goes up 2-0 he has a way to
make it safe like it's just so heavily
favored if hotashi like actually just
woke up and grabbed and like
like was actually blocked i'm like okay
you're on a level that i've never seen
before but that's the thing right it's
all about risk reward management and
that's a lot of what encompasses
fighting game decisions
you know status of symbol is obviously
symbolism making the taking that uh
third game not letting it go 0-3
but as you can see from the standings
like i said interesting situation here
uh days up 1-0 and symbolist 0-1 if
symbolist beats days we're at 1-1 across
the board i'm not sure exactly the rules
for the tiebreaker we'll find out we'll
find out most definitely soon if it's
going to be the case so yeah we are on
the verge of finding out our standings
of group a of course but before we get
to that i want to make sure that
everybody once again gets ready because
we got another giveaway going on perhaps
i'm not sure actually it's not every
break but it is indeed it's going to be
a t-shirt giveaway this time we got the
guilty gear strive t-shirt prize
streaming from our system works you guys
know how they get down they always make
the dopest stuff and a lot of the time
the good to get drive clothing and merch
it's only available in japan so this is
actually like a really big opportunity
for a lot of the n a people in the chat
to win some exclusive merch so please do
so while we take a quick break don't go
in here we'll be right back to the side
how group a falls out
[Music]
i want the freedom
i want to breathe
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
i
[Music]
i'm gonna fall
i want to breathe
[Music]
all that faith that is
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
get them out of your way
[Music]
don't melt in the world
[Music]
you
[Music]
[Music]
get them out of your
[Music]
get them out of your way
don't melt in the world
[Music]
[Music]
my
[Music]
[Music]
sacrifice
[Music]
[Music]
in the world
[Music]
and welcome back to arc revel america
2021 finals for the usfa it's been a
good one already i know you've been
enjoying it james we've been making our
way through group a already two matches
in the books we got one more to go
before we get to that i just wanted to
say how have you been james it's been a
while since we got into work offline in
the studio
i know right it feels good it feels good
not only that but you know having the
players here in the studio as well i
mean you can't tell but they're like
literally right there yeah yeah right
next to us it's it's one of the the
biggest joys just you know be able to
see the players and see their reactions
and everything so
again you know hopefully we're slowly
but surely slowly but surely 100
being safe about it as we do so as well
so i want to tell everyone or i want to
show everybody in case you're a little
bit new to go to get striped wraps you
haven't seen it much i want to take a
look at one of these replays that
happened in our last match it's actually
going to be the nagoroyuki versus a
symbolist match here and nagornovi has
that blood gauge right you can pause it
for a moment real quick people in the
back my mother base
why not you could just take a look right
here at the blood gauge so you see this
blood gauge is really all what
nagoriyuki's about right it's either
gonna fill up very quickly depending on
how many special moves he uses or if he
kind of is able to get a couple of these
big sore normals that you can see he can
kind of drain the blood a little bit but
fighting is this character is all about
waiting for this because look at this as
you can see
symbolism has just been getting
overwhelmed right but as soon as this
blood gauge pops nagoryuki goes into
this mode and his life just completely
drains the whole time in addition to
getting combos so he's eating both
amounts of damage both as the blood
drains from that debuff as well as
getting hit from seoul so that is
definitely something to look forward to
if you're picking up the game and
fighting against the gory you can and
one of the coolest things about that too
is that it's it's not all bad to build
up that blood gauge because we keep
talking about having the two bars and
that makes us 5h just reach like 90 of
the screen or something like that you
know it's ridiculous so there's an
interesting balance of wanting to you
know keep it at that level but then you
don't have access to do another beyblade
which is like the greatest move in the
entire game the best special move in the
game right so uh it's it's such a
fascinating way to design the character
sure it's really interesting and i like
it a lot yeah i think it harkens back to
age-old guilty gear stuff of how unique
the characters are of course and we're
gonna have two more characters not
nagoroyuki this time around ryan we're
trying to settle this last bit of group
a it's gonna be days versus symbolists
here very important match here for
symbolist down 01 to hotah she's pretty
much done here not going to be able to
invest the finals if he falls to days
nowadays of course looking to secure his
advancement as well we shall see yeah
and again you know you talked about
happy chaos you know if he gets knocked
down and doesn't have a lot of defensive
options probably why symbolism is going
to be going with slow because giovanna
we saw what giovanna could do already
you know when we saw days versus hotashi
and uh days probably gonna be trying to
do the same thing but with seoul now you
have the dp option that's something that
you have to think about and respect a
little bit
of course if he gets a little too dp
happy then you bait it out block it and
gets a punish badly yeah and from what
i've seen uh symbolist has had a decent
amount of giovanna experience i haven't
actually seen him in days play
specifically but symbolist has played
against breaker dave pretty often right
one of our premier geos on the west
coast and he seems very ready for the
matchup he deals with whip kick very
well whether it's close enough to
actually get a punish with 5k or
sometimes he'll respond with like a 2s
if it's a little bit farther in that
range he's definitely well aware of what
he needs to do
and actually beat out the 2d yeah the
god slayer there it doesn't matter
though right you see days of beliefs in
the butt and you cannot prevent it from
doing that and another good answer that
2d presents is against instant air dash
jump s from seoul a lot of the time it
actually low profiles that option
you see it's a very common weapon for
days look at this trying to bait out a
whiff throw but symbol is staying very
solid the 6p upper body involved gets
the anti-air and now the combo here get
it for the wall splat
and so many people like to kind of a
flinch after 6p against a giovanna but
you cannot do it with the whip kick and
then again dave's just ready pit bulls
them down
look at this daze is he going to try to
i mean remember uh at the eu finals the
emea finals latif was saying he didn't
want to lose a single game you know
maybe this is what days is going to be
trying to do here he's so far he's three
so far he's 3-0
just finding the offense right there and
that's just the validity of this game
sometimes perfect
coming in left and right oh yeah it's
literally you know in in some of the
other fighting games that you play you
might think oh he got me in a perfect
you feel bad not a guilty gift you just
accept it you just you just you know
brush it off move on to the next what
what in the world
and wake up vortex
the the burn kick yeah because the bird
kick is a high hitbox rider diagram
vortex does low profile soul for a
little while that was it could have just
been like a missed input right it could
have been like an sdp that got turned
around right or he could just be the
smartest player i've ever seen
but either way that was definitely cool
stuff from symbolism and putting a game
on the board early in the set is very
important i mean when it landed i didn't
see symbols react but you know how we
all do that when you do something that
works out you're like i totally did that
on purpose
all part of the plan from the beginning
exactly uh there's one of giovanna's
better strengths right there getting in
for the you know the the dash throw and
then the safe jump set up
yeah these always have those on the back
too yeah he has that safe jump timing
too where like if you go with the dp and
she's going to completely whiff so
simple it's not really looking for the
ibf these we see that a decent bit
against giovanna but not right now
they're there that's what i'm talking
about ibfd on the midi close us yeah but
you saw him just dash right afterwards
and just completely negate the push back
on that
here comes symbolis though with the
pressure again giovanna outside of
having a super doesn't really have any
true involved moves without the dp which
is upper body
and scp actually whipped right there so
they presented opportunities to
just start overwhelming with offense
here trying to oh yeah that's the error
vandenberger i said siblings definitely
have some funky air manufacturers but he
has not been pulling them out today
[Music]
videos out there
that was so cool dude like from the
beginning with someone to feed it out
but the back dash gets clipped and days
is the one breaking hearts
nice good conversion on that chase down
caught the back dash and again you know
it's prob not even necessarily a
reaction kind of thing because days has
probably hit so many of those back
dashes and it's just
another day for him yeah another days
and the thing with giovanna right is a
lot of the time her dash normals are so
fast that like in instances where you
feel like you could back that safely
great instant blogging to the punish
right there was super impressive but
because of that a lot of the time like
this will click her back she just goes
so far i mean remember they buffed that
too yeah she couldn't attack out of the
path right away and now
god take her all the way to the wall
get the clean hit through the wall
look at that no life left
simplest though with no meter
and then yeah again you can see him they
get that set up right there at the same
time he faced it to go with the empty
throw a lot of time it works out that
the ass on wake up though punches are on
the other side
days does go for that sometimes where he
like ends up doing an instant air dash
and lands on the other side for the
throw so similar may have just had the
hard lead there
okay
but then he would do with 5k probably so
i'm not actually sure
there we go there's that safe jump
talking again that's why you've got no
dj out of school but symbolist gets the
bust out of the corner here and now the
pressure again that close slash all day
for the dp there we go the upper body
involved
yeah great starter days i have to do
something over the prc
he's so active tries to chase that with
the banner revolver clashes you can see
similar is always ready for that burn
kick yeah i love that to take the corner
back back that's getting clipped yet
again
yeah that burn cake wasn't even intended
to hit let's just let's get out of the
corner here nice check we talked about
that in the house
it does get the shimmy bass out the
throw days
got caught reaching three days teaching
some lessons right now
well symbol is here oh tried to bait out
a burst but uh days there with the
patience gonna be able to keep the burst
and escape that combo as a result
you see how comfortable daze is i really
do you see him kind of panic bursts
very disciplined about it and making
sure he weighs those are kind of commits
to something dp to challenge remember i
was saying you know the dp he has the
ability to challenge them challenging
the plus frames of giovanna with that dp
oh the anti-air will assist me again
that 2d will just recover so fast lying
for the 6p on the other side
it's the knockdown all backgrounds are
getting clipped but still not giving up
the burst they're going to do it to the
very end that's symbolism with a safe
jab pressure very well done yeah he
tried to bait out the burst the first
time but the longer you let your life go
the more you have to burst and so you
know even though days did not burst the
first time symbolism had to read on the
second one was able to punish and take
it
oh no on the back dash once again days
and he loves doing that he'll just sit
there and wait for you to wake up
backpack
oh god again
for giovanna such a powerful tool
there's another one
he's been conditioned
that is so nasty bro i've seen them do
it before the six each quick rc into the
low you ain't blocking that the first
time it comes out it's just not gonna
happen all right stays trying to get
this to two two will be our first two
two match of the day if he can win this
match
symbolist
look at this and the wrist gauge is
getting cranked along with it and still
not scary oh but this time okay there we
go let's shimmy again finally caught
reaching days would not be the turn just
kept going for it
and that's exactly why you see the
reward it's all worth it in the end yeah
oh my gosh
oh that's he didn't kill him just yet
just goes for the tap dust finishes it
off it is two to two our first game five
of the day between days and symbols and
isn't it fitting that it's like the last
scheduled match of the group like this
could definitely determine who goes on
if he stays
oh symbolist getting the wake up throw
that always feels bad when your opponent
gets the wake up throat like that
oh again lessons are being taught right
now bro get to class
conditioning right now
oh oh no i think it was too far away
from the throw and then
symbolism was the one who ended up
getting thrown trying to bait out
another burst but now he's like you know
what i could that's a throw too oh
simplicity trying to use that lead rc to
convert the combo nice block
yrc
some out of that situation gets the
first out of days
yeah but like daisy he has no leader
right so you see him just being very
defensive with the two knees and then
the five feet anti-air so clean and then
he recovers with a throw that's so smart
when you have your opponent in like a
scramble situation like that where
you're both fighting for your life low
health the dash of throat giovanna is
just such a quick option he was playing
game two mario kart thursday he had a
double dash in there for the throw oh
and look at how far that dash 4s goes
bro oh no
hands and arms inside the vehicle young
man all right through the wall look at
the life lead that daze has
oh the throne's enough to kill as it is
and there we go days closes it out with
a perfect and indeed it will be 2-0 for
days 1-1 hotashi and 0-2 for symbolist
so that means days and hotashi will be
moving on and symbolist is out of the
tournament he was trying to bring about
the apocalypse the end of days
but uh he was unable to do so days is
going to move on with the perfect record
indeed indeed this one might be in for a
machiavellian seven days theory perhaps
we shall see we still got a long way to
go though he will be making it out of
group a in that top seed as well right
yeah both the w sotasha going to be
going down to the second seed from that
group but yeah i really was impressed by
days throughout the set we're gonna take
a look at the replays now from that
match and yeah you can see so many times
yeah that was what we were talking about
right there the night right actually
being the burn kicks that was so cool
but so often you can see days he gets
those knock downs and then he just
switches up between the save jump
pressure and then actually whiffing a
button or making you think the safe
jumps coming and then actually just
throwing you when he lands so it's real
good you can see even when he goes with
that setup that also baits the keys so
it's a really really strong situation
for this yeah and you know you you've
seen it so much days the mo for giovanna
gets you in the corner just rush you
down dash up throw is so important i
mean you know very similar to amelia to
a chip in terms of like you know just
being a rushed out mix-up character but
for her that dash throw i feel like is
so important
yeah and that's one of the things i was
actually really interested in seeing how
she performed offline because she's such
a strike girl heavy character right you
would figure that stuff like that would
be a bit easier to react to offline but
i mean she's just so fast that it's damn
near impossible still but daze is just
like go ahead go ahead and try it go
ahead try to remember i didn't get
counter hit thanks that was super cool
too i love that the abandoned revolver
to go back in and then recognizing that
giovanna was ready so he responded with
an rc of his own like both of these
players are very high level yeah i've
been obviously coming down to the final
but dave was able to clutch it out in
the end going oh and uh going to an o
but i mean it's damaged as these two
characters are pushing out to
again yeah if you're a little bit
unfamiliar with striving you saw a lot
of perfects that said right it was like
a perfect every game i think giovanna
had two so that's just par for the
course though that's what you're gonna
see with this these characters have very
strong offensive games and when you bet
big on defense you could die real hard
if you bet wrong
man i'm i'm i'm from the era of
three-hit half-life man like i i love
this big damage
i'm down with it oh this is such a sick
like you know just trying to get that
extra damage and getting the pressure
there and there was him trying to bait
the burst out there but then does bait
the burst eventually yeah right that's
why he was just going with the the punch
combos the jabs just making sure he
picked something low recovery that he
could chain and react to burst with it
and of course tap dust not really
reactable hold dust is so there's two
different versions you see that orange
glow but the thing is you don't get
combos after tap dust unless you're
blessed like a happy chaos
but oh yeah as you mentioned right tap
does 20 frames i believe charge does
like 28 frames and yeah i mean 20 frames
if you're cracked then maybe you can
react to it but it's not easy at all and
most of the time you're going to get hit
and you know as you mentioned not much
of a reward after it but as a round
ender it's so good and that's why daze
does it as round enders he just needs a
little bit of damage he comes through
and that leads him to quite the
successes you see 2-0 in that group a
himalayan hotashi gonna be moving on to
that bracket yeah but again don't forget
uh symbolist though he is out and will
not be in the top four bracket portion
of the tournament still goes home with a
thousand dollars as does all of our
friends from canada as well as mexico as
well uh shout out to all those players
you're that lucky candidate in comb bro
peppa would have been splashing eddie
all over this set but
that's regardless i'm just a zatto
player fan boy don't worry about me
i mean i'm sad because there's no
potemkin here right oh i know that's
true i always like watching potemkin
buff potemkin man come on that's okay
even though i like watching him you
don't gotta buff him it's cold
i'm sitting here he's chatting like
grapplers for life puff grapplers and
the chat's probably like can you get rid
of him and bring stage i'm on please
please this is what we got oh man
the flame of the chat we have another
giveaway
oh okay there you go astro a4 is going
to be on deck once again so please as
you shall enter in the chat that is how
you're going to be able to get one of
these headsets of your very own by
interacting and utilizing the giveaways
that are gonna be going on in twitch
chat right now again get like happy
chaos play them beats we'll be right
back with the start of group b do not go
anywhere
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
hey
[Music]
[Music]
the most important thing for me is drama
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
darkness
[Music]
[Music]
oh
right
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
is
[Music]
you
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
i was born
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
yes the valley
[Music]
will
[Music]
the world please
[Music]
a little sacrifice
get them out of your way
[Music]
is
[Music]
[Music]
you
are
[Music]
i'll take them
[Music]
get them out of your way
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
group a has been taken care of we know
who's coming out of there it's time to
start group b once again thanks for
tuning in to some arc revo north america
i'm james chen and joined by rindge of
course yes indeed james it's already
been hot and heavy action here group a
is in the books of course it's
phenomenal stuff days hitachi and
symbolism all put on a hell of a show
symbols of course falling just short
close games despite losing the two days
in hotashi rai with daisy hotashi gonna
be already qualified for that bracket
that we're gonna get to here once group
b is over and we're gonna be starting
group b here momentarily yeah so let's
take a look at the players that are
gonna be showing up in this group b
again strong set of players razzo one of
the best leo's in the country flash
metroid the veteran and jonathan tennais
jonathan tenei sorry i keep pronouncing
you were thinking about it so much
before yeah that you had to do the first
time right yeah exactly i got it wrong
again but apologies to jonathan uh but
you know one of the best sato players in
na right now i mean would you consider
him the strongest sato strongest zato in
na probably honestly i would think so
you know there's a lot of strong zato's
i think nokami marlin pie i think
especially but marlon i think
historically the best zotto but has
other obligations nowadays doesn't get
to play as much as someone like a
jonathan teddy right but the thing that
we'll get to jonathan in a little while
of course i was gonna actually go into
my to my right about it because you know
me
of course
we got razzle vs flash on deck right now
and i want to take a look at the
head-to-head between these two it most
likely will be these characters that
we're seeing right now lay over the sky
of course flash metroid has a axle as
well we've seen razzle bust out of the
ram level in certain matchups but i am
expecting these two characters here and
historically i believe it's gone to
razzle side a little bit of the time but
i think flash has beaten them in
tournament before and is capable of
doing it especially with the way he's
been playing lately i thought he's been
playing phenomenal yeah and one of the
things that's really important to note
too is that you know flash metroid i
call him the veteran he's old old-school
player like he's been around for a long
time i could go into his accolades he's
only been talking about jam since
getting here he's like give me my
character that i've been playing for 20
years that's who he got you know second
place in the team tournament at evo
years ago almost by himself
uh and uh one of the things though is
that i think it was frosty faustings he
got top eight over there and was you
know able to beat to defeat players like
adventure and everything flash metroid
you know we talked about how good the
online code is but flash
netcode is but flash metroid is an
offline old-school player through and
through it changes for him when he gets
to play offline and i'm interested to
see how he does up against this razzle
offense right because like even fearless
folk are scared of wrestle on my own you
feel me like they are just so
overwhelming so great on offense that's
gonna be tough and flash you know he's
never scared to throw out the stun edges
and that could cost him here if he
doesn't manage it well however he's
looking strong so far
he hits the buckets like an old school
player too i can hear them joints dude i
mean every time i stream and i hit
buttons people think i'm mad
you weren't sure those buttons work in
those arcade cabinets let me tell you i
can hear them joyce look at you can you
see this again oh my razzle lying in
weight flash kick ansi airing ooh that
actually does beat the charged stud as
shout out to the heavy fireball yeah a
lot of durability on that heavy fireball
here we go the corner position but again
kai with the range which is really nice
he does out range leo a little bit uses
the prc to keep himself safe with the
fist and prc out of there i like razzle
knowing the block afterwards but then
trying to go in and flash getting the
counter hit taking round number one
it's real cool because uh the way flash
i think approaches a lot of
the aggressiveness of this game
considering he's such a veteran is a
control style but he doesn't
aggressively himself oh even the tp
that's so unfortunate yeah wrestling
character that's her round in time yeah
and you know we talked about i talked
about flash metroid getting top eight at
uh foster basketball i'm not splash kid
if i'm not mistaken razzle got second
place there didn't you probably yeah
they've
been one of the premier players when it
comes to results in strive right won
like the first offline tournament over
at pax like have just been doing the
damn thing since the game's launch yeah
they're definitely you know
just one of the strongest players in the
n a region of course
that's why he's here that's why they're
here in the top six so
all right now flash he's trying to keep
control again oh and i love that the
closest directly in the super locks out
the burst you're not gonna get a chance
to do that super smart from flash it
just goes back to his veteran prowess
man always keeping the little things at
the forefront of his mind yeah flash has
been playing guilty gear forever like i
said and so all these little subtle
things are just innate they're second
nature to flash at this point and that's
like something that has actually
transferred from guilty to your game
together yeah is that like supers do
lock you out at first exactly exactly
mr peters you've seen me right now doing
strong's having a strong start
here thanks he already back dashing as
well he's playing such a good b up
against the lego honestly oh my gosh as
i say that risk is the stun dipper
wrestle coming through with the punish
yeah and it's funny too because you know
obviously kai is not as popular
character people don't necessarily
consider him one of the strongest
characters in stride and stronger
characters in strive i should say but
the thing about it is i always kind of
compare he's one of those characters
that like he doesn't have anything
that's inherently dirty
but
he has all the tools that he needs to
win absolutely and right there when it
comes down to a flash your strike throw
game is super good right he just dashes
off in razzle's face
picks the precise moment they want to
move press a button and they get
counterfeit yeah i mean doesn't have
quite the speed or the plus frames as
giovanna but similar strike throw game
better range and he can't get the plus
frames on the fuji oh no oh the 6h maybe
flash todd razzle was out of range of
that but no sir counter here and now
we're gonna get the positive bonus
the plus frames on the stage change
and yeah that that's done that route
and a perfect again like we said you
know a lot of perfects here you can't
you can't take them to heart they happen
in this game
that was so good right there i love that
you see razzle dash blocking the stun
edges right there making sure they get
as close as possible to get a full
punish on kai i believe they even
insta-block that one yeah i mean most of
the characters can just run and then
block by using the dash button but
remember leo doesn't have a bat
well he doesn't have a run
we gotta burst out immediately flash
trying to hold on to this hard here of
course brazil looking time to set does
actually get clipped blocked the first
normal but wasn't expecting the stun
dipper cancel
you know i did say that kai doesn't have
anything dirty his thumb dip was pretty
great
[Music]
probably hoping it was gonna be close
enough to the wall maybe for a break oh
no here we go and he gets the counter
hit combo too look at this damage this
is gonna kill is it gonna kill
definitely straight through the wall
flash metroid
always aware going with the optimal
counter hit combo right there even
shaking his head like damn i have that
on deck i'm impressing myself right now
and that's one of the reasons why i ride
the lightning is you know considered one
of the best supers the corner carry of
that move i mean i actually didn't think
it was going to reach the wall
i mean if i thought it was going to
reach the wall i wouldn't even have
asked the question you know
but there you go flash richard going up
2-0 over razzo so razzo's definitely
going to bring something in let's see if
they can find a a counter strategy here
again you see the beautiful dashes and
blocks all the sun edges i'm so
impressed by that but even though
regardless right flash metroid the one
in control of the set 2-0 even blocking
the guard point here right there very
funky blocks
oh no i hit the with the 2h but it
popped in the backwards direction
accidentally dashed a little too far
under i'm going with the otg right here
oh actually kind of flinching and that's
actually a pretty decent thing to show
kai's because thunderbird is a five
frame low right and that's how you blow
up the guard point stance is with the
low so i like razzle preemptively going
into the
don't want to give flash a chance for
this comeback the tap dust rc oh no okay
at least he breaks the wall with a
non-super so no plus frames oh
yeah and of course uh razzo had the
meter and that's always one of the
tricky things if you break someone
through the wall and they have meter
they can brc and just take take the the
momentum take the uh the aggression yeah
and razzle really does favor those brcs
on the stage change noise dp they were
thrust we've seen flash go for you know
shimmies every once in a while until
razzle actually called out the back dash
with the 2d
very very smart honestly yeah
oh
he didn't think that razzle was going to
be able to block in time
but the dashboards have been so on point
for [ __ ] now has the corner to
themselves smart just to punish at the
back
oh he burst before the super started
really good i couldn't tell if he
actually did that or not and he did
indeed manage to squeeze out that burst
before the super animation started which
allowed him to bypass it entirely
because as we saw with that combo that
flash did to end one of the rounds once
the super starts you cannot burst out
you'll see an x over your burst that
says oh gets the flash kick
ankle breakers let me see that emperor's
eye wait a minute vapor thrust not going
to deal with the prc with a background
that's heavily scaled
not not gonna be able to kill with this
one
oh gossip with the multi lows low slash
low low and flash tried something on
wake up i'm not sure if he like tried to
do something expecting leo to go through
him and like input across i don't know
what it was but we could hear it being
right next to him he inputted something
very hard very quickly uh but yeah
whatever it was did not come out
i feel like he has silent buttons too
and they're still yeah maybe razzle is
wearing headphones so i don't think
they'll be affected by it but i mean
that might be the case as well i mean
i'm just saying like that's how hard
he's hitting the buttons because i'm
pretty sure those are silent buttons and
we can hear of oh just clipping with the
tap dust yeah just trying to drain him
down to maybe one or two more hits
victory doesn't want to get mixed gets
the run up throw again the the classic
of the kai and a trade there's that far
slash from kai reaches so far
you see flash is so good in like
altering his game plan for what he needs
in the moment he's like i just need a
bit of health i will go up and trade
with as far as usually a bad situation
for kai but when it's gonna win you the
round it's great
exactly
here we go look at this pressure right
now oh what a whip punish though by
razzo and here we go gets the mix of
going oh the two age i wonder if that
was supposed to be dp in the first place
but either oh i love this combo the jump
the wall splat
basically playing hand ball you know
what i was going to say flash had the rc
meter on deck actually saves the vote
for a win and punishes razzle's attempt
okay flash now oh nice just jump backs
and throws i think flash is getting him
to be a little more active to get out of
the corner
giving him that d for real
yeah that's a full combo you get a
little otg charge stunners to break the
wall we both got 50 attention what's it
gonna be
oh the other side the brc4 the kick from
behind the back brain kick i've got some
fighter hayabusa in here
oh the gunman guri the head kick
oh man
oh yeah and that's one of the things i
really like flash does a lot too he goes
with processing jump cancels for the
pressure you can see razzles played
flash enough now they were ready for
that just had the 5p on them
oh actually it doesn't go into the stun
dipper just goes to the fireball instead
look at this now razzle with the dash of
throw but back turn and you always have
to be careful with that even though he
can't block he's got that uh counter oh
yeah oh he even heard flash explain wow
this is a little burst oh god i'm back
dashing but the combo did not confirm
but he got to the other side not enough
meter yet
from flash and he recognizes another
beautiful counter hit combo that does
not even look like this guy
he gets them just got the burst he just
got in the flash got hit by the fireball
what happened i don't know what happened
yeah i'm not sure flashes seems a little
frustrated over there i'm not sure if
the fd didn't come out or if he tried
that they ended up getting a button or
just talking to bp surprise chips or
something yeah but yo razzle with the
wherewithal realizing the burst was
coming back at the last moment and using
it to hold on to the game tying up the
set still anybody's game two two flash
wasn't such a good start and oh we
talked about not being able to combo off
the tap dust but if you got the meter
the red rc is gonna let anyone combo off
of the tap dust oh no and now it's
starting to snowball feels like russell
they block one normal flash kick lend it
out
paso knows all these gaps in the strings
they're gonna just flash kick through
them all day and it just makes you so
scared to go on your offense that way i
told you you could be a fearless person
it doesn't matter when you see razzle
there's gonna be some fear in your heart
oh now the shimmy raz there we go the
double jump dust
the wall splats oh man things turned
around so quickly everything's going
razzle's way now flash needs the
comeback of the century for this and
almost definitely in the driver's seat
has 50 attention as well flash oh in a
real rough situation and razzle taking
the set 3-2 after falling in the early
stages of the set as well right coming
back from the deficit i love it yeah and
razzle obviously stoked with their
performance immediately jumping out of
the chair and getting you know and kind
of like silently popping yeah yeah
both of these groups are extremely hard
you know what i mean and i think flash
looked so good coming into this event
still looks good in that set as well
right it went down to the wire both
these players play phenomenally and
these are two top level players coming
into this event so two of the favorites
in the group in the single group it's
tough for them but you can see why all
these players are just so damn good it's
crazy because honestly i feel like if
you played these sets you know the same
sets these same three round robin
players over and over and over again
we're gonna get different results like
constantly because they're all so
equally skilled coming down to the last
game like that between these two players
so exactly let's take a look back at
that set how does it electrifying it was
honestly no pun intended
yeah i mean flash was looking so smooth
and clean at the early start landing
some of those really nice combos yeah
this wasn't enough to kill and one of
the beautiful things about competition
james is the any given sunday aspect of
it and it's not just about like your
performance in game right it's about how
you react to the things out of games
it's how you kind of control your mental
fortitude and we heard flash crack right
on that 2-1 where it ended up being a
burst baited with the flash kick in the
rc
the flash explained we heard him wow and
he sounded a little heartbroken off that
right and then we saw in the next game
razzle just turned up the heat made sure
they took advantage of that situation
and just kind of overwhelmed flash it's
always something to keep at the
forefront of your mind to keep your calm
collection going yeah there was also
that other moment remember where he
looked like she was trying to either dp
against the fireball or something two
very clutch situations that kind of uh
prevented flash from uh
well i'm not saying should per se
prevented but maybe put a little doubt
in his head or for sure the frustration
yeah exactly just kind of took him out
of the game right and when you kind of
get taken out of your game plan you
start letting things bother you or you
start thinking of like wow i can't
believe this happened this shouldn't
have happened and whatnot that's where
it starts spiraling down i feel like we
got a little bit of that in that last
game but of course flash very much a
veteran always making it close and both
these players just so good
razzle very good at flash kicking off of
like one normal as well as long as they
have the charge they're gonna let that
flash kick rock because so often we see
in stride people commit to block strings
that are multiple normals right and a
lot of those times they do have gaps so
the flash kick exposes that consistency
nice kind of flash but you saw that the
burst at the last yeah
i'm not sure what flash was trying to do
there but we definitely audibly heard
him just kind of like oh like a little
bit of exasperation there but then after
that it was just pretty much all razzo
from this point yeah and that last game
arousal definitely ran rough shot that's
what you used to see when it comes to
the lions then you know you never want
to get in there with leo
yeah the brc slowed down you know just
like neutral brc like that at the end
like it's such a checkmate situation
you're like i can't do a damn thing like
everything's slowed down maybe you could
try to bash out a dp but even then it's
going to be tough so this is how group
b's played out so far after that first
game right razzle up 1-0 jonathan 10a
seven up to the plate to take on flash
metroid next as flash looking to put a w
on the board himself exactly wants to
try to get that one one on the board we
saw how the last set played out with the
201 one and the zero two very likely
you're gonna have similar scores here so
flash knows that if you go down o and
two that's pretty much it that's done
because the other two players are
guaranteed they're the only two that
could have beat you so they're gonna
have the one wins so flash has to win
this to be able to stay alive and of
course jonathan tenney as we've
mentioned and i'm going to keep saying
jonathan 10 18.
uh you know honestly uh
i've been watching him every week on the
series e uh event and it's it's just so
much fun to watch him play his zatto is
so good and he's one of the best i've
seen at using obviously 5p as a staple
yeah as a defensive move for zato but he
gets the red rc's off of it really well
and i also feel like he's really good at
the 5h
people yeah uh-huh don't worry i've got
plenty to say about the 10a but we're
going to take a quick break and we'll be
right back so i can gush over my man and
of course continue with group b do not
go anywhere
[Music]
[Music]
don't be curious about me
i don't want you to get hurt watch out
give me
[Music]
nevermind
[Music]
[Music]
oh
[Music]
okay
keep your hands up don't make a big deal
[Music]
deep down
[Music]
oh
[Music]
[Music]
myself
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
i
[Music]
[Music]
oh
[Music]
[Music]
and welcome back to arc revo america oh
i like the lighting on the trophy that
was a clean shot to come back to that's
what everybody's fighting for today
we've already settled the two
competitors that made it out of group a
and we're moving along with group b
right now of course i am rich this is
the legendary james chen i'm glad that
all of you have joined us today to
determine who the best is in north
america right exactly and we already
have our two players out of group a and
uh flash unfortunately who lost the
first game here in group b is trying to
keep himself at a 1-1 because like i
said if he loses to jonathan 10a then i
think that's i mean that's pretty much
it at that point in time so of course
jonathan tennant doesn't want to go down
one either because then he's in danger
uh and wants to keep it uh as as close
as possible with the one oh and now this
is one of the things that i actually
failed to double check on before this
event started but if i recall correctly
flash didn't have the nicest things to
say about nazato players was kind of
calling them out a little bit saying
that they need to step their game up of
course i know latif says the same thing
and latif walks the walk a little bit
harder than most so we're going to see
if jonathan tennis prepared today i mean
i got a lot to say about the kid he's
kind of grown up in the spotlight of the
fgc now he's a very very new to fighting
games like dragon ball fighters was his
first fighting game and he just kind of
since then has really just been a part
of big event after big event right he's
here at arc rival america and he's just
been a stream after stream of these
fully produced big events and he's kind
of gotten used to that type of
environment very quickly now one thing i
want to talk about his gameplay is that
i think he's one of the best at
utilizing jump back brc as a defensive
option you don't usually see people like
completely rely on that but he likes to
jump back and he has attention available
what it essentially does is turns every
jump back into an advantageous situation
for zotto right because you slow the
opponent down so that's something to
keep in mind i actually did watch these
two play against each other in about
mid-january in the e-series and flash
had that in mind already there was a
moment towards the end of one of the
rounds where jonathan jumped back and
flash had spaced himself just outside of
slowdown range so jonathan actually
didn't brc and just fell and john and
flash immediately dashed through much
like what we saw hotashi do earlier yeah
so we got to keep that in mind i think
jonathan is very good at utilizing that
i think he's on the forefront of
utilizing brc in that way but flash is
also i think the best player here
against zotto that's a key point i want
to make as well yeah he is a veteran you
talked about it legacy's still up
against this character and he's just so
good at exposing gaps stun dipper is
great to interrupt the two hits of
pierce and make zotto deal with it as
well so many answers yeah but so far of
course already nice fireball reflects
from jonathan but here comes flash he's
got the first big hit sends him to the
corner he's just about to race and
actually you know the threat of being
able to rc the stun dipper lets him get
away with just doing a raw stun differ
into nothing okay and that's exactly
what we're just talking about right
there right he does the jump back here
and when he sees that the thing is that
it's not that good against flash either
because we've talked about how flash
does the closest junk cancel pressure a
lot as well so he ends up being in the
air even before jonathan and forces
jonathan a brc down like that
oh look at this there's that run up
throw the throw strike game going into
play gets the safe jump set up actually
you don't even need a safe jump set up
again this is hot so now that i think
about it here we go the prc yeah you can
see jonathan oh and one of the hallmarks
of this gameplay is his defense he
really likes to sit it out and block
right there though he gets a huge frog
finally taking kai to the other side of
the wall and grants him some space
but not a hard knockdown so you see look
at that flash after the transition just
runs forward no fear in his heart at all
and flash metroid taking game number one
but flash knows he took the first two
games last time and true still went down
so he knows he cannot uh
feel he can't be overconfident here
absolutely and you know one of the
things oh my goodness that 2s working
out so well flash is so good at
utilizing the fact that you realize he
has meter against you as well like he
just will not stun dibber but he'll dash
of throw because you're respecting the
stun dipper into the rc just so
many good ways to cycle his offense like
i said that's a lot of that you know
better oh
yeah there you go stun different under
his own reflected fireball
like you know i've been saying you've
been reflecting that all day so i have
the counter for that and here we go oh
jumping it up a little bit using that
jump dust as well
look at this pressure
surprising the wrist gauge wasn't built
up farther than that and jonathan today
there's that uh jonathan tenei with the
the the 5p getting him out there too
close for that stun differ
let's catch the weight punishment he
actually didn't get enough slowed down
the dash of throw perhaps expecting an
oppose either way that's something you
gotta show zato players you gotta show
them that you're willing to dash of
throw from very far to discourage those
raw opposed summons
yeah oppose i mean honestly you know
right there baby we're the best moves in
the game not the best whenever when they
first came out to oppose when i saw that
i was like they gave eddie armor what
are you doing
oh look at this though the risk agent
how much damage
converts with oh that was like one of
those twitter clips right there you know
my man's definitely gonna end up on a
high five with that you don't see kyle
hi-fi a lot either but it's gonna happen
today and flash breaking another heart
taking a 2-0 lead oh boy and here we go
here we go again 2-0 lead can he close
this one out right i truly do think he's
the best player against zotto here like
straight up like i think by a
significant margin so this is a tough
draw for jonathan but as you mentioned
jonathan has made comebacks we've seen
flash get come back on so this is
definitely still anybody's game
and jonathan you know earlier on was a
sole player but really has embraced the
zotto i mean i haven't seen him i mean
he bust out seoul for a particular
matchup recently i guess at ramaphost
but he's only going to be zotto at this
point in time but look at this
flash is just still looking so strong oh
and then the instant air dash in the
throat
yeah
after those that stage changes where you
have plus frame so many people have
saved jump setups right so flash just
kind of bypassing that and going with
the empty throw because jonathan's
expecting the same jump exactly
oh yeah and to kill eddie that way
yeah and we haven't even seen it this
set but flash also likes to throw the
sacred edges out after people block the
stun edge you know because it's a
negative frame and a cigar edge will
still catch you it comes out very fast
and and that's another thing too i mean
one of the biggest uh you know
strategies against zatto is being able
to kill eddie properly and you know take
advantage of eddie meters building back
up and flash has been doing that for
like two decades now yeah oh he tried to
sneak in a charge though oh no he was
hoping to get interrupted but the active
frames already out and flashed with an
instant confirm into the super
yeah it looks like jonathan's going for
a throw there but it's in flash
metroid's favor that the throw lands
takes it 3-0 and the veteran takes down
the youngin yeah and like i said it's so
crucial so important because like i said
if flash loses this he knew that that
was it that his day is done over but
here we go we have a situation now where
flash is at 1-1 it's the exact situation
that we saw with hotashi right so now
jonathan tenei is in a dangerous
position because now he's the one that
if he loses this next matchup against
razzo it's up dude jonathan and razzo i
have seen these two fight each other
like maybe 700 bazillion times yeah
man
uh and e-series most of the time is
where you see them fight each other and
yeah if you're looking if you're a zotto
player a leo player looking to study the
match up like the archives for days with
these two and they are two of the
premier players of these characters in
the entire world so it's gonna be it's
gonna be an exciting one too because
it's gonna be two players that are very
familiar with each other with each
other's game plans it's gonna be
battling it out to survive yeah but
let's take a look at that flash metroid
and a jonathan 10 match again and again
you know
like you said
flash being the best player to fight
zato zato is one of those characters you
just have to understand how to manage fi
i mean
basically like a like a team-based
character by himself he's got assists
right and so you have to learn how to
manage both of those things and the
experience that flash has definitely
helped them out in this fight yeah and
it was funny to me it really felt like
flash just made such good decisions
early that he kept control of the set so
long like there's rarely any instances
where i think like kai specific things
that are good against zato came into
play it was just really flash playing it
was a butt off
all right and you can see right here
this pressure and
once he gets you know zato obviously
he's another one of those characters
when he rushes you down it's crazy but
then once you start rushing him down
very very hard for him to escape those
situations and that's what um flash was
trying to do there was that one sequence
where he basically was just constantly
attacking jonathan and jonathan could
not get out of the corner at all yeah i
said that counter here right there was a
result of jonathan trying to throw off
that brc a lot of time you can catch the
startup of normals with a throw
especially when the opponent's been
slowed down but as you mentioned james
if those active frames are already there
and present then your brc situation is
getting blown up so yeah you see flash
now 1-1 at the top here razzle versus
jonathan 10a to determine how the rest
of this view plays out
so uh again if jonathan 108 takes this
it'll be 1-1 across the board and like i
said i'm not sure exactly yeah i think
we might have like games right i think
that might come into play here we'll
definitely find out during the break
once you know that all happens but yeah
i mean i'm looking forward to this very
much very familiar with each other both
these players razzle and jonathan 10a
have pretty much been playing each other
nonstop since the launch of guilty gets
drive a lot of been in this matchup as
well we're going to get to another
chapter of that heated rivalry when we
get back from the break please do not go
anywhere
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
in the world
[Music]
she told me
[Music]
how do we
oh
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
myself
[Music]
my
[Music]
[Music]
hey
oh
[Music]
stay with me
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
i feel like
[Music]
[Music]
hey
[Music]
[Music]
don't leave me too
[Music]
hey
[Music]
[Music]
my
[Music]
oh my goodness another beautiful shot of
the trophy i can't get enough of it to
be quite honest thank you everyone for
joining us once again here at arc revo
america 2021 finals here in 2022 i am
range this is james we've already had
some star-studded matches some explosive
stuff on the table and now we're gonna
get a classic call first drive honestly
yeah and this is the uh final match of
group b to find out which of these two
players are going to make it out uh i do
believe the tiebreaker is going to be
we're going to be counting the round
wins and uh once the two players in this
in this group group b make it out then
it's going to be four players into a
double elimination bracket for standard
double elimination tournament style
indeed indeed but let's take a look at
how one of our competitors actually got
to this moment right let's take a look
at back at the replay i believe we're
going to be taking a look at one of
razzle's replays here yeah up against
flash in that last match right so this
is one of the round stars where you can
see round three early burst from razzle
as well making sure that kai doesn't get
this momentum but you see the jumping
gamer from flash always present and
something that razzles kept in mind and
always the flash kicks ready this might
have been the round where he got the
flash kick through so many of the block
strings you know just
punishing flash for being a little bit
too well actually you saw flash right
there he did one hit into nothing he was
worried about the flash kick in the
middle of those buttons yeah oh and then
you can see right there you're pausing
it when you can yeah and it's just like
such a good instance yeah right there
right when you saw the burst meter just
empty empty on the side of flash in this
situation right nothing built back no
type of gold meter as well you can keep
going with the replay now it's just an
unfortunate situation to find yourself
in especially on the last round like you
know that you're gonna have to
constantly fighting it out in an honest
way even with a dp you have nothing and
just the ability for razzle and the
layout to just kind of mix you up
constantly is crazy and look at the
burst meter at the last second right
there literally with the last hit coming
back
yeah i wish we could see the the replay
with the inputs because i want to see
what it was that flash tried to do there
we maybe have to ask him later on so uh
but you know that was the moment that we
heard flash just like come on or
something like yeah and great stuff from
brazil right keeping their mind in
control right not panicking not wavering
anything like that knew when the burst
was going to come back and affected
used it effectively so great stuff from
razors we're going to jump into this
next match is going to be razzo versus
jonathan tenei the side the fate of
group b and you know the crazy thing
about this too is that these two you
know not only have played each other a
billion times they're also really good
friends as well during the uh maturino
guilty gear event uh that took place
recently we were jumping between streams
and watching the the players on the
different streams and we jumped to razzo
street and they're all in this discord
called yeah
adventure was in there like all the
players were in there so they're all
taught they're all collaborating man
they're coming after the the old school
blood here
[Laughter]
birds of a feather flock together you
know and that's just how it goes
absolutely as you can see here like i
said these two have played each other a
million times i mean back and forth and
back and forth so hard to call this one
out this is another one of those any
given sunday matches at this point super
super difficult i think like
historically let me see here it looks
like historically up against razzle
johnny 108 has done pretty recently i
believe but it's again at any given
sunday aspect it's all about how you
play today and yeah both of these
players are just so aware of each
other's capabilities you'll see a lot of
the time jonathan cena trying to
establish that 5-h game behind the poles
but right there the 6p coming out for
razzo yeah you'll see a lot of times
from razzle 2 definitely tries to use
the sonic boom basically to uh
destroy eddie as well as there are times
where he'll just flash kick hit eddie
and then just know that jonathan can't
get a huge punish afterwards
just to get rid of the egg
you see jonathan he's getting these
small hits here right there with these
two k's we're just not in range for the
2d to follow up oh no we got to watch
out for that big 5 8 from razzo
does jump away from the throw but the
prc forces him back into the mix-up
situation manages to get out but you see
right there the challenge with the 2b to
take out eddie but jonathan also one of
the best at staving off the you know the
basically killing the eddie recharge
time most definitely he's very good at
buying time for eddie to come back and
once again you see him set up shop here
with the 50 tension not hesitating with
the sun boy yeah just using the sword
super right there to build the eddie
gage back up just to guarantee the
corner pressure situation
they've been fd here trying to prevent
this chip but they don't have any air
left here
it's over at that point you know it's
you just don't have enough tension to to
to block all those hits and avoid the
chip damage forever
oh challenge is going to be trying to
dash bash the opposed but jonathan teddy
read that and caught him with the 5p you
know conversion off the opposed all
right so you have to drunk or should
cancel
you put it up again wow i love that
manual clap getting the frog to come
back the right way too
yeah pr or brc is trying to cover that
with button on the 10a again he's just
like control the type of player right
wants to keep control as long as
possible without blocking that crossover
then razzle reading the oppose just
dashing up throwing impressive against
the corner situation does not go for the
air though tried to get the anti-air
with the five feet but jonathan teddy
stayed patient and just blocked
see razzle not letting them summon that
pierced for free either they're ready
with that jab and over the exclamation
point
do not get hit
bro still doing a huge chunk because of
the wrist gauge and oh no burst gets
locked out because your wall splattered
that sucks
all right
just a tiny bit of damage left but oh
boy no couldn't get the combo to keep
going but did get the tack dust didn't
have the side switch combo ready
oh the two edge oh i love that cancel
and then i'll throw on the other side i
can't believe josh is still alive in
this round take too far away from the
top dust no he goes for the low this
time razzle is expecting another tap
test backs off to try to build some
eddie back and he was taken out with the
6p anti-air from jonathan tede taking
game number one oh my goodness 6p war
crime button definitely thanks for the
buffs by the way
much love on that 6p it's definitely one
of the best xps in the game and jonathan
uses this so well look at that cobble
right there too from that counter here i
said you know he flash kicks eddie so
that uh you know the resulting combo
won't do much damage i lied apparently
because that hurt a lot oh nice right
there as well making sure your rc with
the dash store to keep razzle locked in
this corner here oh and the delay to
jump knee catching razzle you can see
they're still staying aggressive
actually got clipped in the middle of
that
box
it will be one run across the board and
i don't remember the round counts yeah
we're gonna find out let's see though oh
jonathan putting a stop
no ankle breakers here
again you know jonathan with that 5p
just one of the best players at using
that calling out the gaps in between the
opponent's offense
some of the opposed as soon as he gets
that space that's something jonathan
really loves doing
you right now get all the way out of the
corner the wake up jumped us to avoid
the throw the hardest of call outs from
razzle right there oh man you'd love to
see it
yeah honestly i really do like confident
defensive decisions like that are one of
my favorite things
everything trying to get away he was
trying to get him that five h range
thought he found it but no instead
melting terrazzo takes another round and
breaks another heart yeah it doesn't
even need the wall break the splat
itself was enough to kill
there we go josh
still one round away from potentially
going up 2-0 i was gonna say are we
gonna see more instant air dash from
razzle they definitely kept it grounded
they didn't lose that one round going to
the air right now that width actually
caught razzle flinching all right gets
the lead charge on eddie forces the
block string to the corner oh yeah
almost had to burst in that situation
because he was going to eat a ton of
damage nice stagger got the counter hit
but immediately burst by jonathan tenney
opposed blocking the jump attack from
razzo oh yeah one with the empty lower
right there marazzo so good at blocking
these empty low 6p put that five inch
away fam wow you need a lower hit box to
hit me oh and remember he tried to do
that on flash and he rat but the active
frame is already out not this situation
for razzo oh my goodness he actually got
caught reaching but razzle already
committing to the instant air dash
oh and then the 2d catching them with
the otg drill afterwards 2-0 for
jonathan enough to kill yeah jonathan
looking really strong here and again
we're gonna we we're in a situation
right now where we potentially could
have one one one across the board but
remember razzo
when they beat flash the pop off why
because they were down 02.
max true
take it three to two
razor just wants to make it hard for
himself
you know wants to make it put themselves
with the back against their wall hey i
mean i feel like that's like comforting
for leos right i feel like they're at
home when like the blood is dripping
from their mouth or that cornered animal
you know what i'm saying like
definitely like that's when they're at
their most dangerous oh man
okay do you see the perfect distance
right there that crowds right under the
leapfrog
the gaping ma as i like to call it
oh the financial vlog this is again yeah
if razzle could find that spacing it'll
pay off big but you can see jonathan
that's why he sets up a pose time and
time again oh but gets rid of and he
deletes that from the screen
too yeah with the armor absorb the hit
from eddie and then quick counter strike
and there's that standing heavy that 5h
from jonathan that i i've said that i
feel like he's one of the best at using
that button most definitely
yeah razzle i want to see if they keep
going with like a guard stance or guard
point stance setups oh overhead and a
counter hit into the super immediately
just wanted to get it over with right
there jon they didn't have any bursts to
lock out or anything like that but still
razzle doing her doing their due
diligence
when a pole is being set up there but
yeah i like that razzle still wrists the
dash right there towards the end of the
oppose right just in case jonathan like
actually drunk or shaded it away
look at this corner pressure now
oh what a back dash and you know what
everything could be
oh that was such a good breaking the law
of aid as well dodging the burst taking
the quarter combo for himself jonathan
on set point
and we may have three weights high
all it takes is one more round
but yeah oh no the back that should have
getting clipped they were just trying to
get some more room after that 5d whiff
getting hit out of the air makes the
needle hit combo on both of the heads
and here he goes oh no the super did not
get a chance to hit but it's okay he
still actually got the eddy meter back
that happens sometimes oh interesting
okay
oh the prc slowed down great techno for
brazil trying to stay alive in the set
here he wants the corner kept the corner
with that burst
all the the opposed there yeah i had to
jump out of the way
so many active frames on that invite
hell just gives it so many
wonderful meaty situations and jonathan
ends up taking it 3-0 over razzo and
like i said most of the time when these
two play against each other the sets are
pretty close yeah yeah i was expecting a
closer set as well james for sure just
because these two have played each other
so much but that's what happens
sometimes when you play against a
sparring partner right on a certain day
you have the right reads and like you
know each other so well that it's just
like one day you actually do know their
game plan almost as good as they do and
when that happens it's unfortunate for
the person that is on the uh the end of
getting beat down yeah and right now uh
the the the the people in the production
booth right now are calculating
calculating tie breakers reticulating
splines you know all sorts of things so
we'll find out we'll we'll get you the
results here but i feel like a lot of
these matches were pretty dominant so i
i what was it the last one i think was
the one that went through two so i think
that's going to be the important one
yeah for sure you can see right here
right in the corner game it was tough a
lot of the time for razzo i didn't see
them spend like instant air dash risk a
lot i feel like i would have been a
little bit more comfortable with them
trying that a couple of more times but
we did see
jonathan's usage of 6p is so good so i
understand why kind of being discouraged
from that is a thing
using the fireballs as you mentioned
always so good at dealing with eddie but
the 6p always on deck to do with those
instant air dashes right they're
actually sneaking behind jonathan with a
vrc drift definitely a tough scenario
jonathan minus six feet
calling out the side switch
and uh jonathan looking really i mean
just
really dominant performance and you know
that's why it was you know surprising to
see jonathan go down to flash you know
pretty convincingly but again as you
mentioned flash with a lot of that
anti-zottlies
like i'm telling you flash is so good
against zotto it was real rough for
jonathan to get him in the group for
sure i mean it'll be even rougher if he
ends up having to face him again in the
double elimination bracket yeah i love
that brc right there got in close to
just kind of stuff out any of the zotto
pressure i love going into the super not
letting him build even more burst back
with a longer combo
and then yeah in the corner right here
you see the clutch back dash actually
avoids the command throw but that's what
we were talking about yeah jump back
into that vrc drift down it gives him a
gigantic punish that 2h starter is
zato's best combo starter period so we
didn't actually get to see that combo
but it still also allowed jonathan to
read the burst react with breaking the
law to get up under it and then take the
corner combo for himself you mentioned
when pierce hits that airborne opponent
you get both hits you get a bigger combo
it was just rough for razzo
burst just to keep the position
and uh i have gotten official word that
we do know
the order of the players now so let's
find out here it looks like it's gonna
be flash and jonathan tenei
and razzo
who had that amazing comeback against
flash metroid
is going to be out of the tournament
i wish we could see the round count on
the screen but uh it's it's all good
it's all good i i trust them i trust
their math so yeah definitely
unfortunate for razzo who has been a
complete monster since this game has
started right i don't like the fact that
they're out of this bracket already is
like astonishing to me because they have
been a such a
competitor that's been at the upper
echelon of results since the game
launched like we talked about the pass
offline event one of the first offline
investments razzle took the w there i
believe they went to an offline event
shortly afterwards and did really well
on top of that so it is very surprising
for me for sure but i mean you again you
look at these pools and
everybody's so good you know i mean
anyone who's out of this is gonna be
like i can't believe they're out you
know and it's just the way it is at this
point unfortunately two players did have
to go out and so we do have our top four
players
the four-man double elimination bracket
is set and ready to go so you guys
definitely do not want to miss this it
is going to take place after this break
well i want to tell the people about red
bull though before we get to that break
you feel me red bull ponder partners
with arxis and we're giving a case of
red bull away right now in the chat ooh
and some nice glasses as well so if you
really try to get your happy chaos on
because you know that man be pounding
the red and put the glasses on and make
sure your steady aim looks good make
sure to enter into the chat right now
that's gonna be our prize before we go
to the break here right just want to say
my recommendation ask for watermelon
flavor
you know i'm right there would you jake
that's definitely the premier red bull
flavor we'll let you all go get a red
bull into the giveaway in the chat we'll
be right back with some more guilty girl
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
the most important thing for me is drama
yes
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
am
is
[Music]
[Music]
don't make a big deal
don't make a big deal
[Music]
[Music]
splash
[Music]
[Music]
oh
[Music]
okay
you know
the
watch out keep your hands up don't make
a big deal
[Music]
[Music]
two small ones that i haven't forgotten
[Music]
please
seems to be
[Music]
once more
[Music]
darkness
[Music]
[Music]
oh
right
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
what's good everybody we have arrived
here with our winners of group a and
group b we got days and flash metroid
looking good looking ready for the
double elimination bracket
uh but of course today's we're going to
start with you a man and i have the mic
here for you not for me that's why i got
it no no you don't hold it
i'm sorry
i'm a professional they don't they won't
let me give it to you i promise i'll get
scolded if i give it to you it's all
good but uh so we're gonna hold my
microphone
but uh but basically so we were actually
chatting a little bit that you haven't
played offline since our gravel 2019
finals it's been a minute this is like
it took me maybe like an hour and a half
for me to be like okay like i'm adjusted
to delay normally it doesn't bother me
but i was like it's been two years
[Laughter]
so it was probably a little rough at
first but were you able to kind of get
the kinks out in
like the locals the casuals the warm-ups
yeah see plus this is another thing too
about like competitive games on like
playing offline with your character it
is super nice to play a character with
like a low execution like floor cuz like
geo she has like some things that you
can drop if you're like sleep like you
know short dash 5k stuff uh especially
on heavies but for the most part
execution is mad simple uh in comparison
to like other games and characters are
play where like i just go offline and
drop [ __ ] i mean
it's okay it's okay we understand we've
all been awful yeah
that we don't want to drop that's
totally good so yeah that is actually a
great point to bring up right it really
frees up your mental space to think
about other things as well right right
right okay so yeah man but what do you
have to say to flash james i mean
obviously you're one of the veterans
here right so i mean how much do you
feel like because you've been playing
guilty gear for what like two decades or
something like that how do you feel like
that experience gives you an advantage
over everyone else
um
does it at all i don't think it gives me
that much of an advantage i think if i
had jam i would have a huge advantage
like let's see if he has 20 years of
experience on that same character like
any game you put him in he has like you
know the
the battle experience from it i need
mine
well so right now you're going with kai
you know who's you know not considered
one of the strongest characters but you
know what is it about kai that's working
for you right now
um
he's pretty much the only character in
the game that can play a defensive play
style and win the tournament i think so
yeah when i watch you play i feel like a
lot of the time you're aiming for
control right like you don't want to
explode in this game full of explosives
i'm not even trying to play i just think
if you go to sleep while i'm playing i'm
like yes
i mean
obviously you know you know i like to
talk about your veteran status here old
school player how different has it been
these last two years just playing
nothing but online you know it's been
horrible
but you know it's better than having
nothing so yeah it's cool so does it
feel good to be playing some offline
matches here
stun dippers hit when i want them to
everything feels good all right so yeah
so actually you two are the first seeds
coming out of the groups right so you're
going to be facing jonathan tenney all
right to start it off how do you feel
about zato in general because i i
actually think flash is the best person
against otto here because of kind of
that legacy experience i just think he
keeps it at the forefront all the
important things so how do you feel
against zato i feel confident and like
that i understand what the character
does but the only thing about zlata
specifically i think in comparison to
other characters in the cast is that the
ways auto players play specifically is
like mad different i mean besides the
fact that they all match 5p like this
that's
[Laughter]
i feel like they're really unique in
like how they structured our offense uh
because a lot of people will do like
they'll push eddie ford and then do um
the i almost called this move something
that does not you know that's not
appropriate
basically they do a pose right and it's
just like when you challenge a pose you
ought to have to what geo anyway you
have to like dash throw or like dash out
of the corner basically but the place
that they sneak it in is always
different or if they even do it at all
right so like i kind of have to get
information first versus auto which i
think makes them like a pretty scary
tournament character uh but yeah that's
a big skill i think about that
absolutely great answer
you're playing against hitachi this is a
florida florida match here right you two
i'm have you guys played each other a
lot you guys are like really good
friends right he's like my guilty your
child
oh the sunning okay so i mean is this
gonna be a darth vader versus obi-wan
like kind of thing
that is the student who's who's darvata
in that i mean you're you're only one
you're the veteran no he's the veteran
right so yeah i mean hotashi is the
student is is this oh i guess the master
gonna tell you i think that's
possible yeah
i think i'm i think i'm the favorite in
our matches but he definitely has a
chance
okay all right
so there we go like i said an all
florida affair coming up in that first
round so that's gonna be awesome to see
but again that's gonna be the bracket
portion of the match uh which will be
coming up but we are going to give
ourselves a little bit of a break here
allow these players to mentally prepare
for the fight i'm just going to expect
to see flash and hitachi staring at each
other staring each other down you know
trying to intimidate each other so
all right so yeah that's it for us here
at our system works we'll be right back
after a little bit of an extended break
to go through that double elimination
bracket get your snacks get your red
bulls ready cause we're gonna be back
with that fire
[Music]
me
[Music]
myself
[Music]
my
so
[Music]
[Music]
is
[Music]
somebody
[Music]
right
[Music]
sacrifice
get them out of the way
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
sacrifice
[Music]
[Music]
my
[Music]
i
[Music]
get them out of your way
listen to your heart that's your voice
[Music]
in the world
[Music]
oh
[Music]
[Music]
a
hello to me
[Music]
forgive me that's not the art
[Music]
keep crying
[Music]
oh
[Music]
those who dream of
[Music]
forgive me heaven help
[Music]
me oh
[Music]
is
[Music]
in the world
[Music]
[Music]
uh
[Music]
tell me
[Music]
[Music]
bringing all your bosses
him down
[Music]
down
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
two small ones that i haven't forgotten
sweets and loud music and i don't like
[Music]
i will
all
lose
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
seems to be
blessing
[Music]
us oh my gosh
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
is
[Music]
keep trying to
reach the other side
[Music]
oh
[Applause]
[Music]
i was born
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
get them out of the way
[Music]
[Music]
you
[Music]
if your
voice
is
[Music]
get them out of your
get them out of your way
don't melt in the world
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
a little sacrifice
[Music]
[Music]
in the world
[Music]
god
[Music]
i want to breathe
[Music]
i want to free them
[Music]
[Applause]
rainbow
[Music]
[Music]
i'm
[Music]
is
[Music]
delivered
is
[Music]
i want to breathe
[Music]
i'm gonna
[Music]
oh
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
i
[Music]
is
[Music]
but i'm not going to be lost
oh
[Music]
[Music]
all my faith
[Music]
[Music]
she told me
[Music]
how do we
oh
[Music]
[Music]
myself
[Music]
[Applause]
a touch of
[Music]
[Music]
ah
[Music]
oh
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
with me
[Music]
[Music]
oh
[Music]
[Music]
i feel like
[Music]
[Music]
hey
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
don't leave
[Music]
myself
[Music]
is
[Music]
[Music]
oh
[Music]
okay
[Music]
is
[Music]
is
is
[Music]
if
[Music]
[Music]
i don't want you to get hurt
watch
out don't make a bad deal
[Music]
nevermind
splash
[Music]
[Music]
and welcome back to arc revel america
2021 finals we are here to determine the
finest guilty gear strive player in
north america big ups once again to our
canadian and mexican participants that
could not make it today they're still
getting a little piece of the change
most definitely but right now we have
advanced through the round robin groups
of course i am rich this is james chen
in case you're just joining us and if
you are you have joined us for the
double elimination bracket portion of
the finals yeah exactly we've already
just finished the pools we had three
players in each of the pools and only
two of them were able to make it out now
they're in a four-man double elimination
tournament and again first prize 10 000
so there's a lot of money on the line
but as you mentioned just to be clear
everyone at least gets a thousand
dollars even the players who didn't make
it such as uh like uh bean and everybody
else right
peppery splash exactly
yeah so there's definitely plenty of
money to go around and we're gonna see
who gets the lion's share of it right
now it's gonna be winner's bracket
action here you can see everybody
starting in that upper half of the
bracket it's gonna be days versus
jonathan and hotashi versus flash
metroid now it's actually interesting i
asked jonathan today about this
tournament beforehand i was like have
you played everybody here and he said i
actually haven't played days me and dave
really wait okay okay so it is a very
fortunate that we're actually going to
see a meeting between the two for the
first time
at the very least offline but as far as
i'm concerned it's pretty much the first
time period that's going to be
interesting so not gonna be able to take
a lot of that information like a lot of
people when you play online when you
play on rank you know a lot of times you
don't run into the same guys over and
over again but at tournaments like this
you do and so building that knowledge
base of what the players like to do when
you talk to top players about other top
players they're always like oh yeah him
he likes to do this she likes to do this
you know and it's so important to have
that information in there
all right so we're gonna see who kind of
brings their experience and expertise
into this matchup and we're gonna see
how they do it right jonathan has played
against plenty of giovanna's dais has
played against multiple zottos they just
haven't played against each other you
can see already jonathan take it to the
skies it's one of those primary
defensive tools ooh i like that cutting
the eddy's short as well to sneak in a
little bit more pressure
oh skip
check days trying to dash in there we
saw that was one of the things that days
did a lot in the matches to give him the
2-0 victory in pool number a
really
enjoying the way he's approached this so
far the prc actually beating eddie and
then maintaining pressure afterwards
here we go and again this is what oh he
read the four dash and caught it with
the throw that was huge honestly as
completely switches the momentum now
jonathan with the corner climbing the
eddies oh into the opposed command throw
there you go you see the oppose you hold
still and then that's just enough to get
the sharknado and then through the wall
jonathan tenei with round number one
yeah these might have been trying like a
wake-up super or something and just got
like a missed input i'm not sure what
but he ate the meaty drills
oh actually justin rage for that does
you can see daze does a lot of fd on the
first normals against zalto trying to
push you out of range to follow up
punishes the back dash gets the eddie
gauge recharge guaranteed pressure again
and actually forces the burst out of
days now obviously
gaze has a life deficit but no more
rounds so gotta use that burst now
it's the block fd in the corner i
actually uh did wonders for john the 10a
made sure the giovanna's pressure ended
far enough away for him to use five
pages
but actually taps the dome piece real
quick gonna get the rc follow up as well
doesn't quite get to the wall maybe
preserving the corner for a little bit
more damage i think that was intentional
right there to be able to keep the
pressure didn't want to lose the corner
position but guess what the 5p five p to
goes half screen well it's like you guys
said it's all it's all you guys
defensively of course zotto has no
invisible reversal with meter or without
so yeah 5p they made it five frames
right they encouraged us to mash it
they only made it faster i mean 5p still
in the grand scheme of things is one of
the slower buttons you know for sure
with a versus five and the four frame
buttons out there but it's good enough
and look at this damage
gonna go for max damage with the shark
as well wow
and that's plus frames here he gets the
eddy summon as well i mean days you
gotta have more than a miracle under
your cap to pull this one back he does
uh whether the storm of the eddy meter
but you see that right there that's
another thing jonathan likes to use
he'll use 2k 2d and then delay a drunker
trade to catch people trading or
something like that and he'll do the
late prc and just get in your grill yeah
it's so smart because obviously the eddy
meter is a resource and so when he runs
out of the eddy gauge or if the eddy if
any gets you know hit and he needs to
build it back up he'll use his meter for
the rc's as a way to buy the time to
build up the other game yeah then day's
bursting here trying to go down 2-0 not
going quietly into the night whatsoever
we fighting back
prc to keep himself safe
fuzzy jumps from jonathan like yeah
definitely can be explained instead he
goes in the back then
he's like
oh man
remember this is what days was doing to
i think it was uh
who was it that he was doing that too he
was reading all oh yeah the back dash it
was hotashi reading the back dashes and
such but now i feel like it's actually
going the opposite direction and now
jonathan tenney is the one doing the
reading yeah jonathan all those players
that really keeps that back dash at the
forefront of his mind he knows how much
players rely on it go to it in clutch
moments so you can see him hard calling
it out right there now we did interview
days before this set and he said
remember zato takes me a little while to
figure out how the players play the
character right because they play it so
differently so he said it might take a
couple of games of intel before i really
start showing out so right now his backs
against the wall he can't afford to drop
another
all
game
here we go a pose into the corner right
now still trapped there you see there
was a drunken shade as you mentioned
yeah exactly he likes that delay trying
to catch for trades because it's a hard
knockdown if it does straight
okay daze is in now plus frames all day
for giovanna
use the rc oh god
here we go combo's into the fully
charged dust oh he's dead james
zotto just like that don't get your
wrist gage cranks or else that health
bar is going there was definitely uh
he's dead jim opportunity
he's dead gym
oh to the corner look at this back to
back needles
now try to see spacing with the invite
hell there again really active that move
so
while it's going away it can still hit
and the opposed keeping anything getting
hit now hitting from the other side the
snaze coming in clutch that was oh so
good prc to convert as well with that
wall break it will be enough damage for
jonathan on set point i really love
though if you saw in that last 80
sequence he manually did the frog which
actually gave him enough meteor to still
have a pose afterwards that's just good
management from jonathan i see as a
non-zotto player it's all magic to me
he's just doing jutsu's over there
he's summoning things i don't know
what's going on exactly so you know
oh man
here we go
more pressure gets out of there gets the
cover hit jump attack big opportunity
for days now again down 0-2 right now
needs to win this round to stay alive
again in the corner how is he getting
these reads james
but now a back throw into the corner got
him locked down and again yeah you air
block you have so much delay when you
land
he's got his first pressure
oh and the risky does happen he misses
the drill oh no
yeah right there it looked like dave was
trying to keep his face right to kind of
avoid the burst he did some spiral
arrows set up i'm not sure if that was
supposed to connect or it was just like
a burst bait but either way jonathan
kind of feeling the pressure at the end
right there noticed it was a funky
situation just trying to burst his way
out but sometimes that's how you end up
clipping yourself and after it missed
jonathan was just kind of laughing yeah
he was like bro like
yeah that's kind of how it goes right
when you're scrambling and you're like
oh for sure my verse is going to hit in
a scramble and then that's the one time
they just don't get in your face yeah
exactly oh but there's five knees bro
he's catching them left and right yeah
and that's that's the danger since one
of the things that makes zato so scary
is just when he traps you in the corner
like that
it's just you know the the the
games like this right the mix-ups the
mix-up
i could not believe he hard caught out
another throw with a back dash had the
oppose out so it's more likely but still
you can block for a long time but it
doesn't matter you can block eight
mix-ups but then the ninth one hits you
and you're still dead oh no
jonathan ended up bursting trying to
keep momentum in the corner right there
but dave's actually backed off made him
with it six-p so
you know it can be also a low jump you
know an empty jump low timing is this
gonna kill
almost definitely does amorphous coming
through the shark takes a bite out of
crime and jonathan 10 a guaranteed top
three with that finish
there you go moving into winners finals
just like that again a four-man bracket
no biases here from uh
no you guys he also he also thinks
aladdin is the best disney movie so we
we conduct on multiple levels you know
what i'm saying you know you know i mean
look even even i'm there
there was one point i could recite that
whole movie practically let me tell you
okay i love it so let's take a look
about our house don't get me to karaoke
man i will see i know we've been we win
so we got to go again soon but yeah
let's take a look at the replays for
jonathan 10a and dave's right there
jonathan with some clutch back dashes
multiple times to really turn the whole
momentum of the game
yeah exactly you can see this pressure
over here and again both characters
without meterless you know true
reversals yeah and this pressure here
but again that jump dust you know
because it's still a jump attack it hits
overhead right so that's why when you
mix it up with the empty low or the jump
dust it freezes you right before landing
and normally you base it off of the
timing you feel the delay so you crouch
but instead it's a jump dust and it
catches you instead okay so when the
zomtos were first starting to present
mix-ups in this game right a lot of them
were doing like empty jump or jump k
right and you could fuzzy block that
like as you mentioned there's a specific
timing to where you can just kind of
crouch and then you'll block the empty
low and before that standing up you'll
block the hot but that jump d beats that
exactly yeah exactly so that jump d i
believe like to try to like be a
difference between the jump d and the 2k
is about 12 frames so you're not
reacting like you have to guess right
and it's interesting too because zach
was just one of those characters and
especially because he changed it so much
with every game yeah uh you know the
eddie moves and such you know it always
felt like that he's going to be one of
the characters that takes a little bit
longer to become as strong absolutely
yeah now obviously he did get buffs in
one of the patches but like
do you feel like
like i know zazo was considered really
strong right now do you feel like a lot
of that was the patches or do you feel
like a lot of it was just like players
like lakeif and everything just coming
up with some of the nerdy stuff
i would say it's honestly pretty even
i think it might be 60 40 in the
player's favor just because i like to
give players credit
but honestly like i i do agree with you
totally that zato is a character that
takes a while to bust open and really
play optimally but the buffs he got were
really good like the five keys above the
five is good but the 5h buff is so good
it really made that button war criminal
status like it advances it gains a
hitbox as it like comes out and it's
just like it's one of the best buttons
in the game the manual summons i even
talked about it right jonathan used the
manual summoned frog which left a little
bit of meter for a pose afterwards
because they lowered the cost of meter
when you do summons exactly so there is
a lot of things that have made it strong
but it's also guys like jonathan tennant
guys like latif gobo ogawa whoever you
want to give credit to right that are
really busting open this character and
making sure they're they're playing how
they needed it he needed it opposed he
needed it baby that's what i'm talking
about you know good looking down
yeah just like just like potemkin needs
garuda right so
[Music]
you ain't have to do that james we were
having fun
james and then you bring up garuda
you know what i'm gonna bring up instead
we gotta give away that one
in my mood
he's talking about garuda over here it's
a guilty gear strive t-shirt prize once
again again man if you follow guilty
gear uh closely like that you know a lot
of these uh merchandise opportunities
our pop-up shops in japan and whatnot
you really don't get that much merch out
here so this is a big opportunity for
the people in the chat in north america
to get their hands on some exclusive
guilty gear merch yeah awesome stuff and
of course you know we've got to get some
more we got to get as much guilty gear
verch out here as possible that's what
we got to do the guilty gear merch comes
out here we need to buy it so they keep
making more
exactly so we're going to give you all a
chance to do that make sure to
participate in chat we'll be right back
with the beginning of the double or
excuse me the continuation of the double
elimination bracket
[Music]
ah
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
i want to breathe
[Music]
[Music]
oh
[Music]
[Music]
i
[Music]
i'm gonna fall
[Music]
oh
[Music]
all that faith that is
[Music]
on today again
[Music]
[Music]
terrible liar
forgive me that's not
[Music]
[Music]
oh
[Music]
those who dream of heaven
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
in is world
[Music]
[Music]
oh
[Music]
[Music]
history
[Music]
bringing all your bosses
[Music]
oh
[Music]
i'm down
[Music]
[Music]
oh
[Music]
[Music]
is
[Music]
is
[Music]
[Music]
why
[Music]
don't be curious about me
i don't want you to get hurt
watch
out don't make a bad deal
[Music]
nevermind
splash
[Music]
[Music]
and welcome back everyone to arc rival
america 2021 another beautiful shot of
the trophy and we are this much closer
to seeing who's gonna go home with that
bad boy of course i am ringed this is
james chen how you doing man i'm doing
good i'm enjoying some guilty gear
action and uh it's been really really
good stuff and kind of excited for this
next match here which is going to be the
florida florida
uh rivalry i don't know if i could call
it a rivalry because like i said they're
good they're good buddies right for sure
but once you get in the game oh man
that's just out the window when you're
in the game i don't care if we're
sparring partners i don't care if you're
my godfather it's all
we all bloodbaths when we come to this
and you know it's kind of something that
uh or flash kind of
alluded to right is that he is the
godfather of a hotashi's guilty getting
your life right he's like when hotashi
came around and first started playing at
the local florida scene he was like who
wants to play guilty gear and flash
turned around like oh you trying to play
my game yeah let's do it seriously flash
was probably across the room it was
probably super noisy but it's just like
the words the whisper just like pierced
the air and it just like focused on on
peter and he was like
what killed the gear and like just like
appeared it's like a candy man you know
you say guilty gear three times flash
metroid shows up so and that's where it
started of course and this is the latest
chapter of the rivalry between hotashi
and flash metro we're gonna get into it
here for striving and this is the other
half of winter semifinals in our double
elimination bracket winner of this moves
on to face jonathan tennant all right
here we go and again it is it's
interesting here because obviously you
know a character like nagoroyuki
outclasses most other characters with
range you know maybe not ram of all
obviously and kai actually you know
kai's bar slash is actually a pretty
decent tool decent yeah yeah so i mean
it's not going to be as
dominant of a distance thing and then of
course you know the the the stun dipper
from from afar can definitely catch uh
nagoroyuki off guard yeah so i haven't
reviewed a couple of their matches prior
to the event uh one of the things that
sticks out to me is flash's a
willingness to wake up and ride the
lightning
definitely be on the lookout for that if
he has 50 attention because he knows
right now goryuki is such a powerful
overwhelming character that these
players especially kotashi being super
aggressive really loves to get in there
and make you constantly block something
constantly deal with something and he'll
just wake up right the line
i mean it's going to be similar to you
know how we were talking about
uh jonathan antennae and razzle how they
played each other
exactly
one of my favorite things about watching
two people who played each other a lot
is they're gonna do things and he's
gonna be like what but it makes sense to
them
otashi already very impressive with the
instant block so utilizing it off of an
air close ass and then actually it's
blocking the follow-up as well right and
we saw a situation right there where uh
latasha didn't have the the blood gauge
had built up so he had the shorter range
5a they immediately threw out some uh
special moves to charge that up i love
this too just bullying with the stunt
edge here i don't think otashi is going
to burst oh no
oh his buttons are incorrect so he knew
that his round was going to in any way
so he was like i will pause this here
fighting i was genius
game of the buttons
that was optimal optimal
he was like maybe i can win with the
wrong buttons but i'll see
oh i can't okay let's go ahead and
change the buttons now dude god we game
everything man
players game every game everything give
us any chance so one of the things i've
noticed already in the set as well is
you know oh my goodness what a great
anti-air didn't bounce on it properly
there you see how willing flash is to
stun engine charge stun edge and whatnot
and we talked about being able to
dashboard those things get close to kind
but that's not a privilege that agory
has he has no dash and now the stun
dipper opening up bullying him in the
corner once again
oh the yrc catching him out of the area
and then making it really safe and kind
of plus
yeah very scary for a second there but
again hotashi almost nearly maxing out
the blood he can't follow it up easily
different punishing the 2h like that
again
a lot of characters have something like
that
yeah reading the willingness since flash
had that 50 percent tension he too us
the last one dipper but he didn't want
to risk it again
oh counter hit slash from full screen
goals riding with the fuji arc very
fortunate for hitachi was a train but
then follows the fireball with a dashing
2h
flash i mean he's a is so good at his
control style of play right when we talk
to him he's all about not exploding in
this game and you can see it right there
right it gets the gory yuki who doesn't
have easy ways to advance forward on the
ground right and his jump is slow you
got a fukio forward which caused blood
to do so against the stun edge it's
really not easy to kind of gain ground
and get in that spot where nagor yuki
likes to play right and you know i'm i
mean may perhaps i'm probably thinking
too far ahead here but i mean keep in
mind too flash probably knows that if he
wins this he goes up against jonathan
tonight 10a who he beat 3-0 earlier yeah
and so you know he knows he has a good
chance of getting into grand finals at
this if he can take out hitachi
i'll give the folks a peek behind the
curtain straight up when we were having
a little break we were talking to
hitachi and the flash flash said whoever
wins this match is winning the
tournament oh straight up yeah he thinks
him and hotashi have what it takes to be
jt so i mean this is definitely a lot on
flash's shoulders right now he has that
mindset already so even if you say i
might be getting a little ahead of
myself i mean he's doing the same
he's like no we me the florida boys got
this whether it's me or hotashi we're
the ones taking it home so yeah you have
to be careful with some of those
situations i still remember one time uh
you know a veteran alex vice said like
he looked at the bracket and noticed
like the match ahead of him he was like
oh whoever gets this one will be
exciting because they know if i win this
and he actually took advantage of that
dude like i said we game everything man
that hotashi actually cut in the forest
it was a little bit early there i'm
actually surprised since he didn't have
meter that was getting clipped but oh no
and there you see right there that's the
reason why flash will wake up with the
live the lightning because hitachi likes
to go for the throw or
or close slash mix-up and so you know
there's not a lot of times he tries to
bait something out so i like oh it
caught the back dash but i liked what he
was doing there
if i feel the br scene into the slow you
can see the punish on the screen as well
whatever flash tried to do got slowed
down and
yeah
that's one of the craziest things about
you know the way that the roman castle
works you can whip punish with it yeah
one of the primary tools honestly people
are starting to use it more and more as
a whiff punish
do it again
oh no flash actually he looked like he
read the back dash but he didn't commit
to trying to attack it
unfortunately always committed we talked
about that right very confident in his
decisions
looking forward just waiting trying to
see if flash and goes with that right
the lineup
he knows too
i mean the intel i got was from the set
that these two play vapor thrust right
through that
now you got to block this now oh chase
is the back dash down gets the burst out
of hotashi because hitachi wants to hear
it now
gold burst this is huge for flats
now he's got the special one combo in
the superb we'll take it at this point
oh okay actually he spent the meter he
doesn't have anything for the ride the
lightning but he does get the wall
splatting the wall break
oh the fukio is covering the whip throw
and get the legs oh she's so fortunate
and that's what we talked about going
back to that
like come on son
oh it's like my favorite uh but again
like he he had the rc and i think flash
was still recovering from the punch and
was able to catch him out of that but i
just i love seeing the gamesmanship
between these two oh it's so great
yeah you gotta remember right hotashi
essentially learned this series
primarily playing against flash like
this is one of the guys he's played the
most against so they're more than
familiar with each other when it comes
to this gameplay style
making slow careful approaches but then
just eats the jump in not sure if he
tried to dp or something and look at
this spending all the resources to make
sure he gets the wall break and the
positive meter bonus yeah that job that
downwards hitbox actually like arrives a
little bit quicker than you expected to
and it beats a lot of six b's
oh yes there's going to be a lot of
blood that he's going to spend here but
he's actually going to drain some of it
with that 4s sequence 6h as well
covers himself but we cover
it's ourselves a that's an excerpt thing
right there
you see the wires oh he's gonna catch
him with the super through the wall
talked about that before right life he's
gonna catch the back dash and again it's
that staggered it's that syncopated
timing that flash you saw him run up and
then thoughtless defense to stop his run
and then fire slash just to kind of
stagger the timing make it look like
he's doing something to bait hitachi the
the back dash yeah and he hit that
cigarette we talked about it and we
highlighted it in the game previously
into that and again right here just
bullying him with these charged thunders
he knows the reason he can challenge now
vapor thrust this is all flash metroid
right now into the crouching kick
too far away for that to connect and
here we go meaty fireball again is this
fast enough to catch it is okay
got the reversal out this is gonna be
good damage but it's not gonna be
through the wall and flash is still
gonna have a sizeable life lead oh yeah
he's gonna pop now so yeah flash
recognizing
okay
it was like hitachi was dancing on the
edge
right because the super drain some of
the blood but then he like went with a
beyblade pretty quick and i was like
like i saw the fukio forward i was like
you can get away with that but another
beyblade causes the pop he was probably
hoping that if he got the hit exactly he
would be able to kill before he got back
to neutral so that it wouldn't pop ooh a
trade and almost a confirmed from
hotashi that would have been so certain
oh both players giving each other high
five
oh no now the bite's coming through that
means the blood is draining otashi
unleashed one more again all delayed oh
yeah he just takes that as a hard
knockdown setup
again blasts at the wake of dps and
hitachi's getting caught by that but it
doesn't matter hotashi takes it with the
throw rc otg
6h you talked about it right a healthy
boy most effective health in the game
i mean it's to make up for the fact that
he doesn't have a lot of movement but
does he really not have a lot of
movement oh he's still pumped anyway
flash yeah taking some time make sure
you get that optimal punch and then the
charge but no that happened to go inside
and on the floor
oh he's just tried to throw the super he
tried to catch him flash oh
he tried to dash back in but hotashi
interrupts with the 2k and raises his
arms and his head goal that's not the
right sport as a baseball bro
it's all over the fence it's not a
touchdown either way yeah
i just i see the text under him says i'm
a genius you know let's hope the ono
panel doesn't show up afterwards but no
that's one thing that you really have to
worry about
the gory yuki's in blood rage man that
super is full screen
[Music]
it's terrifying look at the wind
punishes that was slow this is what i'm
talking about that range that kai has
makes it so that he can kind of go
toe-to-toe with nagoroyuki in neutral
and yeah just to get the pressure and
just to get the shock state as well he
asked me to get in there but look at
this patience from flash and there it is
the stun dipper is this gonna kill yes
slash metroid is that match point this
is looking good for flash and as you
mentioned is the next round opponent
could be jonathan teddy we already
defeated 3-0 oh no but the vapor thrust
big whiff and hawtashi with the optimal
punish ended with the s sequence ooh
even shimmying him with some fukios
getting the command grabs my goodness yo
we're going to
final game
final round for
sure this is a perfect for hotashi a
a statement here
perhaps to go to the final round i
wouldn't have had it any other way
against these two yeah this is a great
example showing just how much these two
have this rivalry how much they know
it's a big damage doesn't get the fire
slash flash tries to get in there the
kick forces the burst out of flash you
can flash start this comeback
get a tough spot he's in the corner he's
gonna get super as well it's actually
going straight into the confirmation
it's a lot of damage
so close
still alive here but is he gonna get a
back-to-back perfect to close this out
oh no no actually i think that's not a
true perfect oh i'm not anymore anyway
here comes flash but now
with the 2k into 2d and a smile on
flash's face
he said i'm so sorry
it's one of those things right at the
very end the flash does such a good job
he baits a lot of time with shimmies
he's constantly dashing in and out
trying to catch the opponent doing
something he's even aware of the camera
to not get in the shot what a champion
flash is thank you i appreciate it very
much sir um but yeah man and right there
at the end right is a huge bet to make
if you're hotashi but as nagoryuki you
got to do that sometimes you got to take
these big defensive bets and he called
out the dashing with the 2k 2d and it's
putting him in the winner's finals
that's right so we have uh darth hotashi
taking out uh obi-wan kenobi yeah you
know when we first we met i was but the
student now i am the master and you know
even though flash was like you know this
don't count on your jam right
you know he's always telling them that
in the
but this is uh we're gonna take a quick
look at the replays here from hotashi
and flash and as we mentioned before
both of these players have played so
often against each other throughout the
guilty gear franchises that we saw that
familiarity on display
and you saw right there that was a great
example of our classes actually able to
use kai's zoning to win the match but
again you know like i said they gave
nagoroyuki all this help to make up for
the fact that he has mobility
problems but like i said
i don't think that does that qualify
does he actually have mobility problems
right he just he has the abilities to do
things other characters do they just
cost resources that other characters
know right exactly so it is an
interesting like dichotomy it's a i
think you can say that
it's not bad movement but we had to come
up with some type of different part that
we haven't really decided on yet i
really love that sacred edge like i
think uh flash's usage of sacred edge is
really good i forgot who started doing
that was it kaneki i feel like one of
the guys really really like abused that
strat and really put open all the other
kai's eyes to him shout out to kizzy as
well i might have been kissing for all i
mean i'm so surprised there's not a lot
of guys out there that just use the true
lot of strata just run up and like
you know sometimes you gotta let it go
i'll tell you what when i play against
the car that does that i lost the light
i'm just tilted off the earth if you're
gonna dash on paper thrust me there's no
way i'm holding on to that but yeah you
see right there closing it out the blood
max uh flash always did a good job yeah
but this is the mistake right here he
forgot that he could slash through the
fireball and you see how much damage
that did
that was so cool man then again yeah the
first time you checked with that
survived another day
yeah raises his arms up and he says the
raw sport he probably raised his arm
level was like oh
he's like no
mixing all of the different
all of the difference but look at this
the super this was clearly gonna kill
but uh hotashi after well put them both
at the final game final round and here
we see another super got him through the
wall and while flash had the valiant
effort at the very end trying to go for
the comeback there in the end that 2k 2d
check was all that it took right about
like you see flash back up yeah i see he
did that hesitation and this time
hotashi called it out yeah and i didn't
recognize like what hitachi's meter was
in that situation but from the way flash
acted it looked like he had 50 attention
because then he kind of like did the
charge on edge then fd blocked to bait
out a super or a yrc so i'm not sure he
actually happened to be attention but
either way hotashi calling it out
effectively he's going to be putting
himself in a winner's bracket finals up
against jonathan
yeah and uh you know you were saying
that flash and hitachi were both saying
that they you know have an advantage
over jonathan
i don't know maybe jonathan tenei heard
that and now he's like oh really yeah oh
really
you know sometimes it's a dangerous
thing to to add that fire to the fuel or
fuel to the fire i should say indeed
indeed for sure so we're gonna get to
that in a little while of course but
right now we have another giveaway for
y'all to participate with in chat shout
outs to astral holding us down all day
holding down the fighting game community
since i've been in this mug to be honest
so great stuff to them that you can
participate in the chat right now to get
a chance to win a pair of a40s we're
going to let y'all handle that get your
happy chaos vibes going on right now one
of many colors to win so there's plenty
of headsets to be had thank you all for
sticking with us and participating in
those chats to perhaps win some of these
prizes yourself we will be right back i
believe with some more of the double
elimination bracket don't go anywhere
right here in our system works
[Music]
[Music]
oh
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
is
[Music]
is
is
[Music]
angry
[Music]
is
[Music]
i don't want you to get hurt
watch
out don't make a bad deal
[Music]
nevermind
splash
[Music]
[Music]
okay
[Music]
i don't want you to get hurt watch out
keep your hands up don't make a big deal
[Music]
flying
is
[Music]
i want to bring it up
[Music]
[Music]
and then
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
i gave
[Music]
but i'm not going to be lost
[Music]
[Music]
is
[Music]
amd
[Music]
i gave up
but i'm not going to be lost
[Music]
bye
[Music]
everybody
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
i want to breathe
[Music]
oh
[Music]
[Music]
i gave up
[Music]
i'm gonna
[Music]
all that faith that is
[Music]
oh
[Music]
welcome back to arc revel america 2021
finals we are trying to decide who's
taking home that beautiful trophy we are
done with the group stages i am range
this is james chen we have our winners
final set but that's gonna be a little
later you know how we get down in the
fgc that winners finals we gotta go
through a couple of loser bracket
actions before we get into that and
that's what we're going to go with right
now it's going to be days versus flash
but i'm just glad that we have gotten to
just show out offline guilty gear strive
everybody at home's been joining us been
winning some prizes and it's looking
good it looks like we're about to get
into it already yeah they're jumping
right into a daze of course with the
giovanna one of the you know more uh
obscure characters these days but the
way days has been played i don't know
why i don't know why but i mean honestly
flash going with the kai also not a
character that you see as often so you
know definitely not one of the matchups
that you would expect to have seen at a
at an arc rivo you know losers losers
semis match
from any region frankly yeah yeah
exactly like they're a little bit more
of the underrepresented side of things
right but it's funny because despite
these characters being underrepresented
they have some very strong players at
the top of guilty gear strike playing
them right we got kizzy on the kai we
got tai ti over on the giovanna in asia
winning tournaments and whatnot so yeah
both of these uh characters have plenty
of high level footage to study from and
we and it's really no surprise to me
that these two specifically have made it
as far as they have yeah and honestly
that's kind of like one of those guilty
gear staples right for sure you always
get those character specialists guilty
gear has always been known for those
players who are just the character
loyalists will not ever change
characters
yeah i mean like if you think about
certain people oh god motifs they don't
really play any other characters right
and that's why flash is begging for that
jam so hard but he's right now
because he's like right now he's like
man yeah
it's happening right now
and all day's looking good
just the slight hesitation before the
close says hit you slipping too again
always just giving the opponent enough
rope to hang themselves and there's that
2d again but okay flash it's the stun
different combo but i'm really impressed
with how ready a lot of flash's
opponents are for his like jump cancel
game because he dazed right there with a
five feet on the board
we got the six speed through the
fireball the upper involved enough to
get through that fireball oh that was so
much damage left on the table
unfortunately for flash
oh frame trapped
uh and again you know one of the biggest
differences between strive and previous
guilty good games is the late canceling
you know after you you get your move
blocked or hit you can cancel it so much
later uh during the recovery so it
allows you to get these frame traps
too close but
you didn't get the punish on the stun
differ
just dashing away enough it's the
blocking that last thunder oh beautiful
spacey real flash he was so confident
that 6p pressed it as soon as he saw the
startup oh and then the thunder isn't
anti-air on the spiral arrow i have not
seen that one before ridiculous doesn't
actually get the kill though oh okay yrc
but challenge with the two was that why
is he blocked no he actually got hit by
it but he's still challenged with the 2p
manages to get the hit tied it up one to
one
in that situation right my mind has been
expecting days to get the dash up throw
maybe try to take the corner for himself
the way now yeah flash looking to bully
a little bit with the stunt edges
flip kicking right over though now he's
in the corner what a tech bro yeah
that's a scary tech because we've seen
dave to dash up and then back dash you
know for the throwback
there you see the stun different it's
the block but still gets a pretty decent
punish off of it you are seeing away but
i didn't want to stick his hand in the
blender right there
actually one with the jump attack and
that's gonna lead to this attack in this
corner catches the back dash
and once again what did we talk about
with days before he's been doing that
time and time again when his opponent's
life is on the line he just sits there
lets you wake up and watches you back
there so you can punish it
so good i mean it's just it's it's such
a strong part of his giovanna game plan
and why days did give hotashi some
problems uh because
again he's just so good at staggering
and timing and hitting buttons that
unusual
in unusual timing is what i like to call
the syncopation
right there just confirming right in to
ride the lighting and get the wall break
knockdown though wow
oh no actually i thought flash was
getting the throw but it was days and
here we go back to back throws for days
uh again double dash that's three throws
in a row
four
i thought he was gonna toss him in the
garbage once again we'll flash marcy and
get some breathing room with the flint
kicks that's a lot of damage drift back
trying to bait out the burst but metroid
flash doing a great job calculating
successfully knowing that that wasn't
going to kill oh but then two need a god
oh my god i'm with the mango
all day every day
yeah
all right we're putting in the 2h in
time
go to the dp you see there's that late
cancel
you can frame trap people looks like
you're vulnerable and you're hoping
people press but what a punish on the
loser arc dashing forward and getting
the throw
he'll take that train most definitely oh
no and that's the thing right you block
a closest from giovanni's like she's
gonna throw me or what's gonna happen
and then you could just get caught
flinching with the 2s cancer right it
looks so simple but just blocking that
one normal just immediately sends so
many options through your brain that
sometimes 2s is just the thing that
works out the best
it's very similar to that uh nagoroyuki
how the hautashi uses that close slash
as well
oh wow
fast buttons that's nice
and very active because of its three
kicks
oh look at that nice confirmed
with her ability to cancel her dash with
almost so quickly it feels like daze
almost plinks everybody
here we go wall bounce into the super
gonna take the light fleet and get the
hard knock down what's the setup here
just goes into the air that tries to be
a little tricky with the timing with the
jump dust but not quite as effective as
the as the zato
that we saw yeah the slow down we tried
with the jump age anyway
ooh just barely surviving oh we actually
listened to blocking the burst
yeah difficult to block the goal burst
right there i think only like minus 10
you got to be real quick
oh one's up from downtown
and gets the throw flash
trying to get i mean i think he was one
of the players who got reversed three
owed and he's definitely trying to
pay that back
he's looking to take control of this set
ari bullying in the corner i actually
have plus frames on that spotlight
not gonna do anything afterwards the
wind kick coming through once again
rearing his ugly head oh my goodness and
he died for it
oh man
sometimes that sometimes the breakdance
fighting super just catches me off guard
i don't expect it to do that much oh
here we go daze has the corner position
already is exactly what giovanna was
what a call out on the back dash to go
for the sweep not even 2k 2d just pure
2d
oh man but the 6p are you knocked down
the corner but the vapor thrust finally
successful here but yeah no shot state
on that flip kick so not plus oh that's
gonna be fast enough to punish before
the slash comes out here we go safe jump
timing blast has to respect it the 6p
anti-air okay side switch okay i like
that from flash and he's going to catch
a backpack himself so here's some good
damage here gets the wall splat and the
wall break
and flash get a game on the board
oh and he does the air stunners the
thing that seals it and a great scour
from flash right daze had been looking
for a lot of 2ds i think even right
there he was kind of looking to catch
kai landing with the 2d himself so
being able to buy your time in the air
with that airstone is very smart
so flash mitchell gets a game on the
board not out here just not out just yet
okay i knew it was accessible challenge
very scary four flashes took his buttons
there but paid off
see how far uh some of david's
giovanna's jumping gets the counter hit
on the 5s and then baits out oh this is
gonna hurt with the dust combo first
dust combo we've seen all day yeah
that's one of the best punishers on
empty bursts like that and again we
gotta stop back dashing mates both sides
getting clipped by back dashes
constantly right it's so such a good
option this game involved for quite some
time it's not a button so you just feel
comfortable doing it while holding back
at the same time juicy you're blocking
while black back dashing but the problem
is we have seen so many players today
get beat up for trying that back dash so
like you said gotta be careful
right there oh no he stopped actually
like empty blocking up the last one with
the move forward some more throws the
forest put that away
oh my god
he's going to get to the other side here
and he's going to get the wall splat is
this going to be enough to kill it is
flashing that joint still alive what not
done
yet what happened with 6h right i didn't
have a fever dream that's what happened
well it had to be like a mistake or
something i don't know
lpn versus gustavo dude oh man
i just know something i know
[Music]
look at this life lead but they had the
shock state that time oh trade and look
at this she's still going to be able to
get the combo gets content oh i really
like that the late burst as well puts
her in the corner the junk feed from the
air doesn't get a full
okay he's got the meter to rc to keep
that oh he hit him with the 2k
but days would not be stopped he
responds with the 5p and is gonna take
it and days
moves on and flash metroid is out of the
tournament in uh what is that fifth
place i think yeah
it's wild too because like flash was
very close to i think winning the whole
tournament
in that very close setting he was 100
favorite against jonathan tennant yeah
straight up from jonathan's mouth he
says the one player i don't want to face
here is flash metroid so
yeah and now he doesn't have to write
flashes out that's definitely going to
be good news for jt but man that was a
hell of a performance from flash 100 i'm
always impressed with his gameplay
especially in strive especially being a
legacy guilty gear player that doesn't
have his character he's still adapted to
this game very well and i think is
teaching a lot of people how to play
strive effectively yeah exactly and it's
just it's really cool for me to see you
know this this happens with like every
kind of game every kind of sport you
love seeing the veterans go up against
the new kids on the block and seeing how
they compete and how they can teach and
learn from each other you know like in
terms of the florida that was ridiculous
florida guilty gear players maybe it
could be considered like a jordan
passing to kobe you know sports kind of
thing so
that is actually a great point for sure
is that two generations of florida fgc
right where flash was it og playing
since before uh reload played slash
reload and then mainly playing ac and
then of course hotashi rising to
prominence and exert and really doing
this thing there so it was really cool
to see both of them because flash didn't
play a lot of exercise if i recall
correctly uh to see them both meet on
this battlefield right
like i said that's just one of my
favorite parts of fighting games where
we see these kind of situations you know
and uh
really cool that these two that you know
flash and potashi had to fight each
other but of course this is about days
here and they yeah with the giovanna a
less likely character and you know i've
definitely heard some players call
giovanna like one of the weakest
characters in the game you know who i'm
talking about
you know who i'm talking but i mean i
love what days is doing with this
character absolutely for sure i think
the character we talked a little bit
about it in during his interview right
is that the character because she's
simple execution-wise it frees up his
mind to think about so much more right
and considers so much of his opponent's
options and i think that's one of the
primary strengths of simpler characters
is the ability to just get your game
plan down get your combos down
relatively quickly so you can start
learning what all the other characters
want to do and how to fight them so daze
has just been showing that non-stop of
course starting with blazblue he's a
methodical type player right but his
harness he said bb tag put him through
it so he's on both sides of the spectrum
right that's why i think he's doing so
well in strive is that he's able to take
both sides of that coin and apply it to
this game anybody who's played bb tag
maybe
did you block oh you died
and that's a similar sentiment sometimes
in this game is that you want to avoid
blocking in the first place rather than
being in a defensive scenario and then
having to bend me right absolutely
absolutely and again you know
i just have to say it this has nothing
to do
you know directly with this but shout
outs to arc systemworks for putting
rollback netcode into everything
also even for persona coming out soon
you know but for blaze blue for bb tag
and then of course strive really kind of
showing the world what good netcode is
all about and you gotta salute roll back
yeah say jamie not here with us today
well that man put in a mountains of work
so definitely salute to that man
absolutely shout outs to say jam and uh
again you know we know he was supposed
to be here uh unforeseen circumstances
prevented him from showing up but we
hope that you know he's he's doing well
i hope maybe he's watching at home right
now you know just being like man i want
to talk about this
that's how we always are as commentators
at home oh we
thank you everybody for joining us we
are moving along in this double
elimination elimination bracket we're
gonna be taking a quick break before
moving on for some more guilty gear
don't go anywhere
[Music]
[Music]
oh
[Music]
uh
[Music]
oh
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
oh
[Music]
i feel like
[Music]
[Music]
uh
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
don't leave me
[Music]
oh
[Music]
and welcome back to the arc revo america
finals i am here with james chen and
days dave still staying alive in the
bracket feeling good uh i'm feeling all
right i to be honest with you i'm like
kind of in uh super i'm trying to win
this mode right now
so that i'm kind of like i've been like
a lot quieter since i lost the job so
i'm not gonna lie because i'm just like
how do i fix what happened like i really
want to win right so i'm just kind of
trying to figure things out right now
interesting well i think you did a good
job then considering how much you're
trying to think about that not taking
that into the flash set right were you
able to kind of like not think about
jonathan yeah i think one of the things
i'm definitely good at especially like
in tournaments is just like tuning
things out i don't really like even if
you've ever seen me like play a
tournament on stream because i do stream
this game quite a bit especially
tournament runs
especially when i'm losers like i
typically don't say anything
so if you ever watch satoshi for example
he's really animated like he'll like
he'll show you how he's feeling
basically like he wears his heart on the
sleeve
it's all up here basically like if i'm
exploding you will not see it
every time
it's so silent yeah i don't hear a
pop-up
i got a job that's basically it let me
ask you i mean
obviously giovanna is a character that
has kind of seen a taper off you know
people not playing as much you know do
you feel like she is as strong as a lot
of the top tier i think she is right
below top tier she's like right there
okay uh the interesting thing about like
the top characters depending on who you
ask of who they are in this game of
course i think what's basically holding
her back is that she doesn't have
anything
that's like her return isn't super high
for how she runs her offense like ram
for example she has assisted offense
where she throws the sword you got to
deal with the sword explosion if she
guesses one throw and she's wrong it
doesn't matter the sword explodes yes
still keeps her turn but geo can't
really hide behind anything plus the
system mechanics are relatively good at
like you know dealing with her she's a
very interactive character so when
you're wrong you're really wrong and
like you can just die off of it uh which
you know it's just like the
you know kind of thing that happens when
you play a striker okay at the right in
any game but i feel like that sets her
apart or just like a little bit lower
below those characters basically because
everything else is really good for the
system i would say like she has really
high damage really simple confirms you
know good buttons good space control
good pressure you know carry and such
yeah so would you say then that it's the
experience of the giovanna players that
have kind of gotten her in the upper
echelon of the results now because like
at first it was like kind of like like
you said it started tapering off a
little bit and now we see the rise again
is it because of stuff like that
uh i think the people who like the
character will play her basically i
think that's really what's keeping
everyone playing right now they just
think she's cool
of course like it also depends on if
you're kind of suited for that kind of
thing like me i usually play shoutouts
in fighting games i'm like so i've been
running strike through my entire fg
career
in this game i feel like i'm rocking
with the the weights off because like
you can't react to throw
so hitting good players is very hard and
this game is like it doesn't matter how
good you are you can't see it you have
to guess yeah i like the opportunity we
were on commentary we talked about as
soon as you block a giovanna close ass
like oh everything just like your brain
starts firing signals because like you
can't react to anything it's just about
guessing in that situation now is there
any player right now that's still left
in the bracket that you are concerned
about or do you think you know you could
take out pretty much anybody at this
point i'm here to win nothing
i'm not worried i'd like to hear that i
like that's what i want to hear all
right so yeah definitely a good stuff
from days i'm expecting you so do you
have a before we go to break do you have
like anything that you can give us a
little tidbit of insight on the jonathan
tennant match if you get there
uh
you want to save it i understand if you
want to say it
he's in the ultra sweat mode right now
he's definitely in the other room
watching his interview okay okay
all right so we're gonna keep it on the
low yeah we're not gonna reveal the
secrets thank you so much dave for
giving us our interview we'll be right
back with some more guilty gear strive
do not go anywhere
[Music]
oh
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
god
[Music]
and finally
[Music]
big
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
save
is
[Music]
[Music]
but i'm not going to be
i'm gonna
[Music]
the
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
i want to breathe
[Music]
[Music]
is
[Music]
oh
[Music]
oh
[Music]
all that faith
[Music]
so
oh
[Music]
okay
[Music]
[Music]
if
[Music]
is
[Music]
i am just
[Music]
three
[Music]
[Music]
don't make a
don't make a big deal
[Music]
nevermind
splash
[Music]
oh
[Music]
okay
[Music]
good
i don't want you to get hurt
and welcome back everybody to arc revo
america for the 2021 season we are
nearing the end of this thing and uh
look there's a lot of cool stuff that we
are going to see today so
yeah keep it locked and loaded to say
the least what are you talking about i'm
just talking about the matches right oh
yeah i'm not
i'm talking about the things after the
matches you know what i'm saying you
know keep it locked
but we'll get to that when we get to
that of course right now we're gonna be
going to that winner's finals of our
double elimination bracket it's gonna be
jonathan 10 a versus hotashi yeah again
you know uh no surprises to me here
these are two players that i see
very often week after week at the series
e tournament uh and hitachi jonathan
tennais constantly placing high every
single week after week in fact otashi
has like uh four wins of that series
already the most out of anybody and so
honestly like when you see hotashi play
in that tournament you can see he's
experimenting he's testing stuff it
almost like
he's actually even like kind of said
like he feels like the the north
american needs to step up more because
his eye is on the
players from overseas his eye is on like
latin that's true like all the asian
people
he's not satisfied to be the best in the
us or the best in north america he wants
to be the best in the world now you
mentioned how he's been jaw-jacking with
a few of the foreigners most notably
being latif who is considered i think by
many to be the best zatto in the world
even the surpassing gobo
in this case i think this is an
interesting match because of that
because this can be considered the best
zato in north america jonathan
so let's see how much hotashi is
prepared for this matchup by the way i
also wanted to correct a mistake i made
earlier speaking of people from all over
the world i was mentioning that how the
canadian players and the mexican players
wanted to make it and i mentioned being
bean was not one of the qualifiers it
was chetu as well as uh excellencer
right yeah so uh sorry about that a
little bit mistake there but uh for sure
sad that they all couldn't be here would
have really loved to have seen them
because i
again fighting games are a universal
language and like getting players from
all around the world is like my favorite
part i was gonna say i feel like when
you ask people about fighting games and
what's part of the greatness about them
is that everybody those offline events
where everybody comes together right and
yeah unfortunately couldn't get
everybody here today but we're slowly
surely getting back to that point i'm
sure we'll see some of these heavy
hitters square off very soon but yeah
when it comes to this match i'm very
excited about it because i think there's
a lot of things to talk about as you
mentioned we have the hotashi latif beef
being in this matchup right but also
it's thought that zato is pretty good
against the gore you guys right probably
one of his worst matchups so that's
something to keep in mind however i
asked jonathan prior to this event how
he feels about facing against hitachi he
told me that hotashi beats him more than
he'd be totashi okay so that's something
to keep in mind despite zato being at
advantage in the matchup right and we
talk about it you could see if nagoro
yuki ever gets like two bars of blood
and gets to the other side of the screen
you see why zato has advantage of this
matchup he can't do anything zato is
just summoning eddie over and over again
spamming specials at him and nagoryuki
can't get through it so that's what
jonathan is going to be aiming for right
on the other side nagoryuki if you get
in zato has no invincible reversal he
has nothing to threaten you with and of
course you know we were talking about
when nagoro yuki has you know
effectively the most life in the game
well zato has like some of the weakest
yeah
some of the weakest guts uh you know
weakest default defense modifiers and so
we've seen the damage that nagoro yuki
could bust out and when he touches zato
zato is a sad sad sad person yeah
exactly so he gets hit the wrong way
we're gonna be calling the character
eddie again because he's gonna be dead
okay he's gonna be dead i'm telling you
it's gonna be up there for the to the
puppet to actually you know manifest
once again and take control of the human
body if hotashi has his way of course
yeah but yeah jonathan is going to be
trying to prioritize getting that range
that zato is so good against her
nagoroyuki ad which is that like full
screen outside of 5h range i can harass
with pierce i can do eddie drills you
gotta jump and like do a b to try to
guess my anti-air timings you know we
have talked about you know the gory
yuki's limited you know natural movement
you know resourceless movements and you
know anytime jonathan tanay has at least
one bar if he gets the eddies started
blocking and it's hard to get away from
it he can go into the sword super and
then follow it up and it's a guaranteed
push all the way to the corner right
it's harder for nagoroyuki to
to deal with that because of the limited
natural movement but
if you could never get anything started
that's a problem
all right well
yeah speaking of though jonathan today
trying to get the corner position but
you can see already watashi one of his
priorities is gonna be getting up to
that level two bar so he has access to
that far 5h
yeah exactly and it's good in that
situation where you have something
already cornered right now sato was like
i don't know what to do the five
agencies is gonna rule my life and then
a bite to close it out give him a quick
hickey on the neck kotashi taking the
first round yeah and again
i just i love the whole concept of it
because you know i almost kind of
considered when uh nago first came out i
considered him kind of like a reverse
sin you know
you're building the meter instead of
draining the meter but the thing is sin
didn't really get any advantages when he
got low on the food meter but nago
getting the advantage when he's in the
high blood meter is just it's such a
cool
twist on the mechanic sure and that
hotashi has it exactly where he wants
him once again
two and a half a blood meter oh my
goodness that means jonathan can't press
anything
oh look at this wrist gage oh my lord
it's there it is it's flashing and
jonathan this is a hallmark of his
gameplay style if you follow him through
other games he is a very incredibly
defensive player he's willing to block
it out that is a huge part of this
matchup though if you're able to absorb
5h with a pose you can actually drunk or
shake cancel and punish the frog as you
saw
he's got the opponents there we go guess
the counter hit and now he has a bar oh
no but he's oh my goodness yeah charge
does he needs to walk he didn't get it i
don't think that 68 was what he wanted
and unfortunately for jonathan taney it
all comes crumbling down first match to
otashi hotashi even shaking his head
knowing that that match shouldn't have
played out like it she did
yeah
i think he's also looking for a little
bit of water maybe it was just
but now here's the thing right now you
have said that jonathan tennant is a
relatively newer player right sure and
this is one of the this is going to be
and in fact we were just talking to
hotashi about this how he was saying
early on he had a match that kind of
almost broke him mentally a little bit
and how he's had to toughen himself up
this is one of the hardest parts for
newer players now obviously jonathan
today's won tournaments and he's pretty
dang good and you know hasn't had
problems but again it's still
in an environment like this this is
different absolutely you know and and
now to build on top of your point it's
not even only just the new guys that
still get affected by stuff like that
right you mentioned hotashi was very
worried earlier
all the way off the edge with the tilt
apology man's another one that uh he has
oh yeah consciously worked on his mental
composure though right and it's taken
him a while to get to where he is now
it's just one of the toughest things to
overcome in competitive fighting yeah
exactly and you know what i mean
honestly like i
i see it and it's something to me that's
so admirable because it just means
that's how much we want to win it and so
you know you know whenever i see players
get you know emotional
angry or just upset
dude that makes me a fan
that's what's going to make them one of
the best players in the future honestly
whether you could survive that and come
back stronger
oh yeah off that prc they don't want to
let jonathan keep building that corner
pressure here we go he's got the eddie
started doesn't have another meter
though for the sword super like i said
but now there it is no more eddie game
so he's just killing ty with the 5p and
the 2p
casey yeah see again invite hell so many
actor frames able to catch the back dash
oh he's oh no okay actually he still
gets the combo but a couple of times i
feel like jonathan has been right there
to take the mat the round but a couple
of mistakes oh okay you can punish it
yeah just just
i mean i get trying to be safe with the
two ptp but i still want to come up with
a command
oh i don't know but he did block he did
yeah he blocked so yeah never mind never
mind actually yeah yeah minus seven on
blood pop right so you can't punish it
even on block there's the opposed again
tap dust into the gaping ma again
wall splash no not dropping the combo
this time jonathan's in a's getting the
positive meter bonus but hotashi had the
meter for the brc but nice throw
oh goldberg
wow jonathan waking up with the 6p
that's coming in hot oh he didn't get
that second two h that's definitely the
optimal combo there he's got meter now
for the sword super no actually he
spends it on the prc due to a mistake i
i'm seeing some nerves on jonathan's
side definitely a few errors here and
there jonathan seems like he's playing
like extra careful
let's see i'll elaborate more after this
round
we're just trying to swing with that two
s classic coach
throwing out two s two s two s oh he got
the burst yeah he's waiting he wanted to
see how much blood that was gonna build
because he risked that
kind of thing he jumped dust oh no is
that the jump dust that he used to stall
himself in the air to avoid the 6p
what a decision by hotashi that's what
you got to do in this match alright when
you're getting in on zato it's so easy
for him to anti-air you because you have
no way to alter your trajectory besides
that jump deep yeah and again jonathan
by all intensive purposes should have
won that round and so again hitachi with
the clutch comeback
okay now he's got the meter but no not
going to spend it just yet going to
spend it for the combo but nice burst by
hotashi to basically trade resource
trade burst for the meter on the prc
got him with the gaping ma keep himself
safe on the lift throw into the shark
super that should be able to take the
route
with the old tg at the end it does most
definitely god scare you for a second
we're like oh my goodness it's not going
to get another chance to play but no sir
nago has that protag power why won't you
die you know it's like the character
never goes away yeah
you mentioned that you
feel like you're singing some nerves
from jonathan tennant right and i i
really do feel like he's playing even
more safe than he usually does he's a
very much a control priority player but
oh no everything could be going into
chaos right now we got goal burst we got
bites on deck you just gotta guess now
yeah this is definitely a sad chaos here
when you're
trapped in the corner oh
and now gets in there with the beyblade
brc you can see how slow that jump is
thanks to that and just wait until he
landed got the bite oh counter hit for
sure going to be able to combo off of
that and so hotashi one round up takes
one more he goes up two to one ozashi
was so smart with the way he played that
corner pressure sequence right there
knowing that jonathan didn't have any
leader to rc himself but he was slowed
there was going to be nothing but
respect coming out from jonathan and he
threw him
all right yep you see staggering the
follow-up of the dp
just to try to frame trap jonathan
however playing very safe there we go
absorb and then launch with the drunker
shade
and then gets the combo
sword to build up the eddie gauge and
get the hard knock down guaranteed
needle
trying to bait out something trying to
make out a yrc right there with the
breaking the law didn't give it to him
evening up the life with two slices
oh nice job outside and actually with
punishing as well because of that rc
challenge with the five feet there there
we go launches eddie with the drunken
shade again now coming trying to
pressure with just repeated lows
out there oh actually sniped it what a
6p yeah beating the far ass
and there it is again okay burst
surprise but yeah it was a perfectly
timed burst from hotash to be honest yep
if we could get past the needle just in
time oh yeah that was gonna be
guaranteed death in that situation so
now look at this both that one one round
of pieces wow just starting out with a
kick right in the beyblade half life
gone already
that's a hell of a way to start from the
gorilla hot she already pulling him into
the corner once again rc to keep that
pressure i mean he's building all that
meter back because of the positive bonus
that's a real good look
and then the air throw off of the prc
one of the scarier situations to be in
claude the glock shout outs tasty steve
oh and then stuffing any approach with a
2s that is one of the gory yugi's best
buttons one of his best stop sign tools
and right now tashi looking like he's
going to be in pole position yeah i love
i love that angle right there with the
silhouette for player one against the
the monitor back there it's so simple
back into it here
cool remember historically
jonathan does say this match up they
were so tall
versus players
yeah you know in the end you know you
can have bad matches with either
match-ups or whatever or you could be
using
quote low-tier unquote characters
but you know
a player makes such a big difference
when you have a player like hotashi you
know in charge of a character like
nadine
oh and then checking jonathan has done a
good job checking out the forward food
pressure
gets combo off of that is gonna be
enough to kill not fight he said oh my
god cause he tried to input amorphous
with it
oh but he's still gonna win after the
counter hit 2s into invite hell jonathan
tanay goes up one round trying to tie
this up two to two
but you're right though jonathan has
been stuffing the ford fukio a lot jab
or throw pretty much every time that
watashi has been aggressive there's this
full screen you were talking about you
saw jonathan get full screen and here we
go he's gonna try to keep the pressure
going he's got a sword super no actually
he's gonna go for this instead and nice
the brc gonna make it so he can link off
of the 2k
yeah that was a fuzzy setup too with
that jump ass off the brc
doesn't exactly he knows it's uh oh for
real
already in the corner here chase there's
a challenge and there's that rc that he
always goes for and kristoff right there
right
i didn't see it but jonathan did he's
keeping his eye there you must have been
so confused for a second you're like
what are you doing jonathan
but you know look jonathan is his auto
player he's used to looking down there
exactly
source management very much in tune with
jonathan tenney right there so good
stuff keeping an eye on that nagori just
waiting for him to wake up pop off and
now we are in a final game
man oh man okay here we go remember
winner of this goes into grand finals is
guaranteed top two you get in the top
two you're guaranteed sixty five hundred
dollars nice little checks
five hundred dollars oh man
right now hotashi taking his time here
definitely uh one of the signature
characteristics of hotashi right he
doesn't really rush into games in the
middle of the set he'll take his time
he'll make sure he reviews some of the
things that are going through his mind
calms himself down because as you
mentioned he's very conscious of the
fact that he can tilt right so it's
honestly a joy seeing players really
take care of themselves it's crazy too
because i was just telling him i was
like i would have never guessed
he's so calm you know he speaks softly
you know people have said that he's one
of the players that you know talks trash
and lowercase you know kind of thing and
you know i would have never guessed you
know he would have that oh actually but
look at this is what hitachi does i
thought he was dead to be honest
barely living at that point he does get
the 2s counter hit honestly it's going
to be tough
watashi and the gory don't have that
greater defense he can definitely get
ran through yeah and again zato just has
this ability to lock you down like this
here we go he's going to try to move
forward and he has a positive meter
bonus the yrc to slip through the tap
dust what a timing by hitachi
match point and i can't believe there he
did the yrc i feel like there's been so
many instances where he could have and
he's held back every time well that was
such a clutch defensive choice
that's what made it for that
talking about clutch defensive choices
and then there's the empty low he hasn't
gone for the dust option we talked about
still got hit by the 2s couldn't quite
glide over it yeah the back dash
oh
yeah but he was like whatever it's all
good it's all good it's all good he
definitely made a hand motion like yeah
i deserve to lose right there i had
already taken a drink of water you got
it
that's just one of the things we're
fighting is right if you play him a lot
you'll find yourself in an instance like
that oh but he actually committed
oh what an instant no he actually does
get good time
look at this half life away from trying
to take us but remember oh no he did he
did that a little too slow wasn't a red
rc so it didn't get the explosion hit
off of the 5p nice defense by hitachi
weathering the storm oh and he actually
recovers in time to get a close cess got
the tenney immediately first trying to
keep control of this corner here 2h the
active frames he respected it after
killing eddie yep and now eddie's back
though gets the oppose and now send him
out the drill for the lockdown but you
see him back dashing away from the 2s so
we can't keep him locked down this is a
big hit for hitachi now oh
boy look at this through the wall
we've seen 2s work out time and time
again for zato here what's it going to
be he just jumps back yeah hitachi
adjusted with a 2k right there great
stuff from jonathan
he got the counter hit oh he got the
trucker shade and actually traded one of
baghdad's brc and one slice is all it
took taking the remaining life from zato
and putting hotashi in grand finals
winner's side
he died james how did he die right there
bro give my man some guts please
i tried i'm listening trying to get it
and tell them what they're talking about
what y'all what y'all talking about over
there
i can't believe you did command grab
[Laughter]
talking a little trash right now but
again
what play from hotashi just showing why
he is considered by many the best in
north america right now and again you
know i talk about how much you know
flash was
is a veteran and stuff like that but
again hotashi one of the best players in
exert with that health for a long time
he was one of the players who was able
to take out the japanese you know
players and remember because asia kind
of ruled excerpt for a long time but
then you'll see in general for a long
time players like lost soul and hotashi
started stepping up and really could
challenge them and that you know hotashi
is keeping this up here and you can see
that he's one of the strongest in the
game right now yeah exactly right that's
one of the beautiful things about
fighting games getting the community is
getting as old as it has right is that
we get to see these generational battles
we get to see people grow and come back
from adversity and really start to
cement themselves where they were once
rookies now they're og's they're
veterans of the scene i mean that's what
hotashi's accomplished here you can see
right here this is the run back or
excuse me the uh replay set up the match
yeah i mean honestly i credit hotashi
with a lot of the nago tech in n a
because i still remember do you remember
the beta like when he got
nerfed you know when the blood gauge got
increased a lot more and everyone's like
why did you do that you've destroyed
this character and after the game came
out hautashi was one of the players who
still played him and i was like wow why
would you play him he got nerfed so
badly and he he saw something he's
definitely saw something 100 it was cool
to watch the way nagoryuki developed at
the beginning of the game right because
a lot of people were like yeah the
resources seems like too much of a
deterrent for him to be good right but
then we saw fame fame 96
and i think fame and hotashi are two
sides of the same coin right like i feel
like fame was the water drinking right
there
oh yeah and the water drink the moment
where um i lost my train of thought
yeah yeah and hotashi are like two sides
yeah so cause fame uh really i think
developed a lot of the control style of
the goryuki really showing how good the
character can be once you learn how to
manage your blood meter and hotashi was
the one that came up with the sets we're
like i'm gonna pop max blood and make
you hate your life you know
so it's it's like yeah
he's like i did it but again hotasi now
guaranteed at least 6 500 dollars here
in grand finals he's either gonna take
first or second so it's either gonna be
6500 or 10
000
dollars
jonathan jones is lucky though because i
was going to tackle him if he won right
there i was going to get up from my seat
and tackle him so
he got lucky
we'll see though he's still alive he's
going to be in losers bracket action
going up against days in a little while
i would make fun of you but if shine pot
pot was here i
but yes thank you everyone for tuning in
for the viewer or tuning in as viewers
of course and of course we got another
giveaway for y'all in the chat astro
holding us down once again for another
headset prize giveaway so we're gonna
give you guys time to get like happy
chaos enter into the giveaway in the
chat and we'll be right back with some
more double elimination bracket we're
winding down don't go anywhere
i know
is
[Applause]
[ __ ]
[Music]
[Music]
the game
[Music]
[Music]
this world
is
[Music]
[Music]
i don't need
[Music]
we already know the smell of the game
uh
[Music]
[Music]
what
knew that they cannot change society
so instead of reflecting on themselves
[Music]
themselves
so
can't you see i'm blazing still my heart
is blazing if the words kill me i don't
need
is
[Music]
[Music]
know the smell of the game
[Music]
oh
[Music]
[Music]
a
[Music]
forgive me that's not the
trailer
keep crying
[Music]
oh
[Music]
those who dream of heaven
[Music]
is
[Applause]
[Music]
oh
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
um
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
bringing all your bosses
oh
all of them
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
and welcome back once again the light is
shining down on the trophy just like a
shine on all of our competitors this
week and everybody's been putting on the
hell of a show and we are already at the
top three james it has been decided
these top three players have been the
best this weekend so far and we're gonna
decide who gets to face hotashi in grand
finals momentarily that's right again
third place five thousand dollars second
place sixty five hundred dollars
and uh
oh
looks like players are asking for
counsel here but uh
they'll handle it were you saying yeah
no but and then 10 000 of course
for
first place so a lot of money on the
line here hitachi already guaranteeing
himself at least 6 500. and again you
know look i'm not saying that you should
you know
keep sticking around but you know after
the matches are done
i'm just hinting at that a little
something you know
but you definitely want to see these
matches as well because uh again
days when we interviewed him he said
he's here to win this
and uh honestly jonathan tenney was so
close to beating hitachi going down to
the final game final round so you know
jonathan wants that revenge and days
he beat hitachi in the pools yeah so if
you're talking about revenge i mean daze
is the one that i'm vengeance right here
yeah he is coming for everybody right
now he wants to make sure that he gets
his run back so that he ends up taking
this to himself because jonathan is the
one that put him into that lower bracket
in the first place yeah
so here we go
days and jonathan because remember when
we were interviewing he was saying like
he had to think about what to do and he
didn't want to reveal his seat i wasn't
gonna bring it up yeah the fact that you
know i asked for a little bit of tidbit
about some insight about what he wants
to change against jonathan and he was
ultra bones he was like
my friend i gotta make sure i beat the
man before i tell you what i did to do
it exactly exactly and you know that's
that's that mentality you can't give him
you can't give him anything right yeah
yeah that's why i was like you know what
respect that 100
100 but you can see right there days on
the left silhouetted against the screen
and you see jonathan tenei uh
right there with the trophy right behind
him
and here it is it is going to be the
match that they played earlier is going
to be giovanna and jonathan i'm sorry
giovada and zotto
jonathan jonathan won yep exactly almost
did the you know thing where you call
like you know eight on uh get gamer beat
instead kind of thing so
oh man ride it in on the wolf we're
gonna let the intros play we wind them
down now nice here we go
yo calling out the trash talking here
here we go there you go this is losers
finals here days versus jonathan today
oh jonathan teddy the one that put days
into the losers back into the first
place already pressure in the corner
mounting you see him catching him trying
to wiggle out
oh immediate burst here
just 10 seconds uh gone on the clock oh
look at that brc that was last one in
the world that jumped brc you talked
about but here we go the corner position
wow okay the the the leapfrog did not
connect interesting that was weird i
guess the frog was too far forward and
the first stage is oh it's
either way blocks the empty low base has
definitely been more opened up by the
jump d delay
for jonathan to keep in mind you know
that's going to come and surely nice
look at that brc gets the preview there
it is the jumpy exactly as we said
good stuff jonathan immediately
switching it up right there well done
one thing i want to highlight about
dropping this gameplay he's gonna be
putting in the corner i'm gonna have to
start guessing though but uh when he
puts a pose on someone in the corner he
often just tries to hit them because
people are expecting command throw so
they get hatred they get hit trying to
jump out
and the snakes can tend to extend the
combo out exactly right yeah oh
anti-air dude it slices it dices it
julian's your fries
oh my god oh 6p finding its mark yep and
then launching uh eddie to get the
sandwich gets the gaping ma in there but
however okay no never mind gonna use the
sword to keep the pressure going
it looks like he didn't get his dash
jump right there he just got regular
so that's going to allow that kind of
killed a lot of that momentum that
jonathan had
jonathan does actually dash out and it
punches with a throw of his own on the
ground it's going to put her in the
corner burst out from days that's still
a big w for jonathan he's been
yeah i mean jonathan was trying to
like i said he lost so much of that
momentum there it's just it's so
difficult to deal with
in those situations especially for you
know zotto who the eddie is such a
resource you know you make a mistake
like that you lose that resource
there goes a lot of that pressure that
you have
oh you know going over the five d's
riding by hell building that eddie gage
back nice goes up for the air throw
misses but had was that eddie's like
behind him to keep him safe yeah
he's like appears coming out or
something
actually gets him with that second hit
of the low and then he's just trying to
wiggle out try to do something on the
wake up gets counter hit and jonathan
looking in control
yeah i mean dave said that you know he
was hoping that he had a new strategy to
go up against johnson but
jonathan right now goes up 1-0
wow that's who that's coming through
before the 2d was huge
oh challenge yeah not letting him get
away with the hill and what a trunk or
[ __ ] he actually got the counter head
that was gonna be a big combo still did
good damage even with the burst
and there we go frame trap
yeah people like to press something
under that 6p from giovanna but they had
mater as well to make that whiff kick
safe and keep pressing his advantage
again just the black defensive
guts and
scales for for forzato and he's just
eating damage all over the place
surprising nobody punches some days on
either of those buttons but does find
this corner positioning anyway and once
again the timing works out always
catching people trying to flinch yeah
it's that like i said it's that
staggered timing that syncopated timing
oh here we go another heavy kick gets
the burst out of jonathan but jonathan
needed that verse to keep alive the
opposed was still there to stop the jump
attack
and the snakes came through in a clutch
right there ooh blocks the cross up brc
covering his whiff right there but oh i
was gonna say that
and take them all the way through the
wall getting caught by the gaming mod
one time look what it cost
oh each other
yeah 2d low profiling it oh when he
actually gets the throw to send this who
was tying up the set even actually
taking away jonathan's second heart
[Laughter]
that button does everything now to be
fair she's one of the only characters
that can't combo 2k into 2d you know
because
judy's quote weakness is the startup on
it but
as a zoning kind of poke as a space
controller as they keep my opponent
honest move it's so good yeah it's got
so many good properties here right you
see jonathan adjusting his defense right
there not pressing at the 6p this time
close friends the indiana magnate he
even got counter here too he must have
tried to uh back dash in the drc or
something
oh nice wire c
and now
oh
jonathan just betting big on the 6p the
upper body involved coming through in
the clutch oh yeah you see you just jump
out didn't want to be sandwiched by it
oh cop the back dash
rubble
actually gets the throw afterwards this
is huge for jonathan oh and that should
be it actually yeah days got clipped in
the middle of the drills remember when
we were talking about how good jonathan
has been at checking that forward fukio
now he's kind of doing the same thing
here checking daisy's forward dashboard
okay it's just so hard to do man like
consistently checking the forward
momentum of these characters especially
one as fast as geo is incredibly
really impressive hell just to force
them to block give it enough time to
build back that eddy gaming game
out again so backs off decided to give
time to build up that meter which is
gonna give days an opportunity there we
go counter hit
gets the burst out of jonathan yeah
that's why jonathan go with the burst oh
when he gets the opposite the last
second he knew days couldn't resist
swinging in
oh he actually does kill eddie on that
though he tried the manual clap cancel
this could be all down the drain all
come crumbling down for jonathan and he
was hoping to get two five keys into the
rc
you missed but is he gonna get oh my
goodness
they didn't even need the wall splat at
all
that was the coast to coast right there
the van terminator
well done right there and yeah man i
mean the five ds have been dropping on
his head time and time again he's got to
watch his dome piece for sure that was
really the tail of the tape in their
first set too he got hit by a lot of
dust
he is trapped in the corner already
six p's on deck you see setting up for
that uh again that super meaty invite
hell
now there's the oppose
watch it over there
oh you see how good that two dudes made
like it actually counter pokes people
from so far away it's one of the best
uses of it
again jonathan
he's a little quick to cover his whips
with prc sometimes oh
damage like
like nobody's business i think there's
certain instances where jonathan can
like get away with whiffing these
buttons without prc and like he's been
caught without meter in really tough
situations sometimes because of that but
regardless he's winning the set so it's
working out more often than not nice
yeah good fd right there on the 2k
actually pushed him out of five
oh and just the media is close as you
hardly ever see zapdos just run up and
close as meaty like that
taking a page at a giovanna's book oh
and once again the dust coming through
to bless his forehead knows the timing
of that sequence knows that there's
still enough time to throw out that
eddie right at the last second before
the meter drains tried to combo into the
vaping mob didn't quite get it nice
block on the empty low oh and you can
see the cobble he gets off the new flame
drunker shade as well huge counter hit
combo actually building up time to get
the meter and the eddie gauge oh heck
okay here we go guaranteed uh any
pressure in the corner into the shark
super the shark the wave interacts weird
yeah so it actually does whiff he had
the burst out in time sometimes it
actually hits afterwards it's definitely
a weird super but either way john the
tenney in the corner here trying to jump
out the brc actually just slow him down
but still challenging with the jabs put
something in the sandwich pressure again
yrc to keep it with the 16th challenge
well done from jonathan shutting down
the spyro at the last second to put
himself in grand finals and get that run
back that's right and that means that
unfortunately days run is it is the end
of days jonathan tenney has uh brought
about the apocalypse now and uh he's one
of the horsemen
exactly i mean one of them maybe
you know gotta have a battle of the
horsemen man i just realized too that's
the only person days lost to
oh really jonathan
you're right double jeopardy double
jeopardy two own groups and loss to
jonathan twice in the double elimination
bracket ooh indeed gonna be working on
that zotto magic 100
exactly but yeah let's get to the
replays of jonathan 10a and days to see
how jonathan teddy earned his way back
into a grand finals position right we
talk about the corner pressure with both
of these characters so often we talk
about the reliance on back dash for
guilty good stride players you saw that
open up right there the brc delay prc
delay is also a big part of the game's
meadow
yeah and here you see right now just the
defense from jonathan being very patient
he did get the back though i don't think
he ended up winning this one i think uh
yeah uh daze gets the hit here yeah but
but still that is one of jonathan
tanay's um
i mean honestly one of the
biggest strengths of jonathan today
really is his defense i always called it
uh well i guess i can't call it the
tenacious defense i have to call it
tenacious defense now so uh but you know
he really does have some great defense
and he's willing to block things out he
plays defense like a veteran of fighting
games right yeah he doesn't really try
to bet early and try to like steal turns
or anything he like blocks it out until
he figures out the best possible uh
situation for him to challenge right and
that's why it feels like his 5p and his
5h is better than everybody else's is
because he knows to withhold the buttons
he doesn't get counter hit trying to
mash on them he finds those moments and
he seems to be his
his connection rate on those
counterpokes seems to be higher than
most other zotto players and you know if
you're a bit unfamiliar with fighting
games and you're sitting here like
wrench james why doesn't everybody just
play defense like that then well if
you've seen the wrist gauge in this game
and that purple meter right yeah i tried
for one to do but even if you are like
i'm gonna just block it out i'm gonna
sit there and just wait and see what my
opponent does a lot of the time that
risk age gets cranked so high that the
one time you do get opened up it's 90 to
100 yeah so that's why it's i mean
incredible that jonathan is as
successful on defense as he is
so great stuff once again from all of
our competitors days again showing out i
was very impressed by his giovanna
throughout the tournament he's
unfortunate he just wasn't prepared
enough for the zotto matchup it seemed
like but i will definitely be looking
for days to wreak havoc throughout
strive's lifespan and again you know
like a character we don't see that much
that a lot of people you know most of
the giovanna players i feel like dropped
the character
and just kind of moved on to other
characters and such but
who would have predicted a giovanna in
third place of the arc rivo n a america
finals right i mean that is shows how
impressive you know
days is and maybe how wrong all of you
are
your father okay even days himself said
characters just under top tier you know
but he did say also that people that are
playing the character play her because
they like her right yeah and i think
that's a common sense of being in guilty
gear i know a lot of you like this
figurine we're going to give away right
now you feel me let me get that graphic
what what what oh you like this
character too james the giant viking
standy if you've been playing around if
you haven't been entering the prizes and
the giveaways in the chat now i know you
will don't get it i know y'all at home
i'm busting out my phone right now
jumping into the chat you know
if i win the statute is that rigged i
mean
you get mad man out here entering the
giveaway as you all should as well we'll
be right back make sure you get your
entries in and we're gonna have an
interview with our grand finals
[Music]
oh
uh
[Music]
oh
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
myself
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
oh
[Music]
don't leave me
[Music]
myself
[Music]
welcome back everybody to arc revo north
america finals we have our two
grand finals competitors here hotashi
jonathan tenei let's talk to the players
for a little bit i'll start here with
you uh hotashi what's going on talk to
me about this now obviously you're the
current reigning north american evil
online champion here you've been winning
a lot of the locals and everything like
that what is it that makes you so strong
in guilty gear strive right now
nagoroyuki
oh book
when i started guilty gear i had i
really wanted to be like the special
snowflake where no matter what character
i was playing
everybody could see it's me hotashi
that's that that's the playstyle and
i've made it
so
like
regardless of anything i'm determined to
stay true to myself
i mean winning is a nice
i just want i just want the twitter
clips you know you know how it goes
trying to get on high fights i
understand i understand yeah so i mean
you know what's interesting is you know
we've often talked about you know the
the rivalry between america and overseas
and such you know
during the exit days your lfelt was one
of the you know defenders of america
exactly defenders of america exactly and
now you know i feel like you're your
eyes are on the overseas you know you've
been talking with latif you know and
such you know
how do you feel about the strength of
america right now uh be able to go up
against everybody from around the world
there's there's a bunch of players in
north america i would honestly consider
them as strong or better than me days
is here
uh 10a of course
apology man
shine potemkin
uh you know ramola deb oh yes
the cow
uh
everybody's encroaching right
everybody's figuring out nagariyuki
getting more consistent i mean did you
see 10a yeah
that was consistent
speaking of timmy man can we just take a
moment to see how cool our hair is right
here we got a little you know what i'm
saying
so you're here right i've been playing
against a good amount of nagoroyuki
most people think that zato is a pretty
good matchup against the character
how do you feel right now considering
you've lost the hotashi in this
tournament once but you guys he kind of
gets the better of you most of the time
but not all the time right definitely
winnable yeah i think it's winnable i
mean
i i definitely don't think i'm like i
think zazo does way better against nago
than i make it look like i think that
matchup is like really good for him i'm
just not good at the matchup so that's
that's unfortunate we've played like so
many times
and i'm really proud like even though
you lost i'm real talk really proud of
you because
there's so many things you've crossed
off the list like we're talking about
defense in neutral fuzzy jumping to
avoid command grab
focusing on my blood meter so i can't
like free-wing you right you know what
blood rage you've done so well so like
i mean i'm gonna be trying my best how
wholesome bro that's what i'm talking
about some baby face promoting soften
them up right now
i ain't buying none of this bro what do
you want me to say yo ten are you free
that's that's how you're doing marvel
right that's facts he knows a little bit
he knows about marvel he knows what's up
yeah that's right
so yeah man do you have something like
that i'm curious how jonathan wants to
respond to what hadashi had no i i i was
just role-playing
he said i don't know
nobody is free that's true that's the
truth i think it's definitely been
apparent that everybody at this
tournament had the capabilities of
winning it and definitely just been
showing out on a high level so that's
been dope to see so i mean
i don't really know what to ask at this
point i just want to get to the grand
finals bro all right this is like such
an awesome moment here
i'm going to take the floor let me take
yeah yeah 10 seconds i'm gonna this is a
real talk
this tournament is
one result
you got matched on like you got counter
hit
you guessed wrong you know your combo
dropped
uh this this tournament is just like one
bad result doesn't undo everything
just like for sure if
i win it doesn't necessarily mean i'm
the best
uh
we just have to look for it after this i
think to echo your sentiment i think
that's something that like ramallah
talks about a lot right it's like
dealing with loss and not putting so
much pressure on yourself and really
trying to carry that baggage with you
right because it is so easy to lose
especially in this game you can't hold
yourself against it happens so fast it's
to me it happens to everybody i've gone
on to
i've lost because i dropped the combo
i've been quadruple perfected yeah you
saw me play latif
so yeah i want to give you the floor
anything else to say before grand finals
jonathan
um
[Music]
i don't know not really yeah all right
let's get to it i know we're ready for
the grand finals i know y'all ready for
the grand finals one more break bear
with me and we will get to it and then
we got all kinds of stuff after don't go
anywhere we'll be right back
[Music]
[Music]
oh
well
[Music]
go through dream of heaven
forgive me just help me
[Music]
keep crying
[Music]
i must is
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
oh
[Music]
oh
[Music]
[Music]
oh
hello
[Music]
down
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
somebody
[Music]
the world leaves me
[Music]
a little sacrifice
[Music]
[Music]
we have arrived at grand finals you can
see one of our participants sitting down
the other will join him momentarily
thank you all for sticking with us here
at the arc rebel america finals it has
been a long journey we are arriving at
grand finals now hotashi vs jonathan
teddy hotashi put him in loser's bracket
jonathan earned his way back for the run
back and it's going to be a hell of a
grand finals yeah again i mean it was
down to last game last round i think it
was on the winner's side over there now
obviously this is going to be tough
because jonathan tenei needs to actually
win two sets he's in the loser side of
the bracket and hotashi's chilling on
the winner's side so you have to be sent
to losers to be eliminated jonathan 10a
needs to win three out of five and then
another three out of five to take this
tournament absolutely and i just want to
give a shout out to all my zotto players
out there because zato is in grand
finals of every single one of the finals
that's what i'm talking about
in asia finals in the emea finals and
now jonathan 10a completes the trifecta
well done
us potemkin players are just gonna sit
here james when we start playing get
together you told me you picked biking
to counter pixato i don't feel sorry for
you bro okay well that's fair that's her
but she's not quite the same yeah it
doesn't work like that anymore exactly
exactly oh i know zatto players hated
that one not as much as jacko and exert
probably but still you know
yeah look at jonathan he's been running
a mug showing how great zalto is as a
character right really doing a good job
managing his resources effectively
picking the spots that the character
excels best at utilizing those five h's
and those six p's the war criminal
buttons right there he just knows what's
up man yeah exactly and you know hitachi
was saying it best that jonathan tenet
has just been playing like out of his
mind playing very well you know even off
camera he's just been saying had nothing
but kind things to say about jonathan's
play here uh this weekend and you know
like i said i i have the pleasure of
being able to see him almost every week
at series e and man he's so good and and
and it wasn't even just like he showed
up at series e and was one of the best
like he was obviously good but he's you
can see it's just getting better and
better and better every week
yeah it's really dope to
see him just grow as a fighting game
player continuously same thing with
hotashi right obviously hitachi came a
little bit before his time but we've
watched him grow up in the fight game
community before our eyes and doing
amazing things like this on the
nagoroyuki keeping it a buck too like
why are you successful in this game he's
like i picked the right character but at
the end of the day right we talked about
it carried by it by nagora
but he mentioned right he's like i want
to make sure that when people see the
character they know it's me and he has
accomplished that 100 like i said he was
one of the sides of that two-sided coin
to developing the gory yuki's meta in
the first place along with fame so yeah
he's done a great job i think jonathan
as well has kind of innovated a little
bit i think he's a pioneer when it comes
to our scene for whiff punishers and
whatnot i see him do it more than almost
any other player so yeah i think he's
quite good now jonathan was hard on
himself in this matchup right he said i
actually think zotto is better in this
matchup than i make it look right
specifically and i honestly agree with
him i do think he's a little reckless in
the matchup sometimes i think he kind of
spins his rc a little bit to
willy-nilly to try to cover these whiffs
that are not completely him in danger
yeah so it'll be interesting right
obviously he's in grand finals he's done
a tremendous job and things have worked
out when he always just prioritizes
keeping as much control as possible
that's why he already sees those with
you right is to make sure that at any
moment hotashi cannot take advantage of
that opening yeah but here we are this
is it the grand finals here who's going
home with ten thousand dollars
is it gonna be hotashi or jonathan tenei
it's going to be nago versus
zotto as expected
yes most definitely completing the holy
trinity of grand finals in our arc rifle
series i'm loving it most definitely and
let these intros rock because this is
indeed grand finals we kicking it off
get it let's
go
and once again
shout outs to all the players like i i
definitely want to give a shout out to
all six players who are here this
weekend all very good but these are the
two that's left here we go starting off
right away jonathan janae backing off
trying to build some uh some space so we
can get the zotto so he can get the eddy
going and gets a burst out of hotashi
right away
if you're just joining us watashi isn't
winner's side grand finals so jonathan
has to be in the whole set to get that
first place oh and that's the thing that
we were talking about right when
jonathan doesn't have the rc meter of
his own a lot of time he just falls back
down to the ground opening the muffler
throws nice block on the dust that's
something jonathan highlighted about
hitachi coming into this event how good
he is at blocking those
and you know it's crazy because we've
often complimented jonathan's defense
yeah and then he's sitting here saying
oh my goodness
this is ridiculous but he did get open
up here and he's going to be able to get
the sword so he's going to have another
eddie guaranteed and he's got another
meter as well so he can either use it
yeah there it is i was about to say he
could use it to continue this pressure
for the empty low okay but this is
dangerous if he gets the wall break here
otashi has all that meat expect the brc
there it is he does go forward but y'all
are just blocking that actually jumps to
command through as well living for a
little while very close to popping and
that five inch does not save them
jonathan weathering the storm oh
boy
again
really smart from jonathan to be keeping
track of that blood gauge as you know as
much as hotashi is and i really love
hitachi going to that command grab right
there right we talked about jonathan's
willingness to block it out so he gets a
command through after the first play
well done
all right here we go towards the corner
position gets the knock down here we go
the media invite out
like i was well trying to close that
distance get the plus frames going
that's why yrc came out real quick yeah
and sent the meter to keep the pressure
going in the corner with the yeah with
the yrc
here we go oh
and eddie got hit prc to save himself
and he's gonna be able to beat the 5h
too far away for the first the catch
yeah the sword just doesn't have a hurt
box like that he's completely whips and
now he's gonna be running amok over
aggression and then one more command bro
to do it the quick rc into the s as well
all right one round a piece jonathan
tenei looking really strong in the first
round but here comes otashi getting the
momentum and getting the half damage
again that's the half damage starter
right there smells definitely glass half
full half empty it doesn't matter it's
half something yeah plus it's all
discouraging
oh man
when they're harassing with the 5k
though oh and then baiting the burst
down with the brink of the loss this is
with the jump attack
yeah unfortunately hotashi he knows i
can spin all the blood because he's
going to die right there well done 1-0
what a star for moist his own
not moist enough over there what are you
shaking his head up
i'm i have no comment i'm gonna let john
i'm gonna let uh hitachi
speak for themselves but again two
games now away from ten thousand dollars
and uh cementing himself another big
major win in this uh in the past year
great recognition from jonathan right
there cancelling the piers into another
pierce what they saw the airborne hit
oh we tried to press something they got
the man thrown
all right so here we go yeah and you see
like that whiff of the close slash
that's hotashi trying to make you think
he's vulnerable that's why he whips and
then immediately close slashes and
the prc covering the way if you want to
get intimate that's my type of game
right there the bite out of crime
hotashi
still rocking and rolling
oh
the half damage starts again he like
that you
honestly it's not that bad for zato
because at least you get back to
mid-screen but now you're in the corner
once again took a bite that means the
blood's draining he's got a hundred
percent tension as well you gotta watch
out for that reversal super he's
influencing i can hear it yeah so now
he's gonna go for another sword super
perhaps no he's saving the meter tries
to go for the commando missed it went
for another one but oh tash he said no
you know remember how it ended last
night otaku said i can't believe you
went for that command throw
and he called it out again hotashi
back-to-back reads and look at this 2-0
hotashi
he's taking a swig of his drink here
without having accidentally sacrificing
himself otashi
one game away from
becoming the arc revo america champion
big alts right now
look at that already has jonathan teddy
in the corner once again putting out
those close friends with the cloning
sneaking in the command grab he's just
doing such a good job switching up his
usual offensive rhythm jonathan cannot
play defense
yeah and again you know
there was a lot of modesty when hitachi
was talking about
who was the best in n a but right now
hitachi is showing
a lot of players something here he is
gonna prc keep the pressure with that
close slash is so good cause it catches
people trying to jump away as well yeah
it just brings you right back to the
ground jonathan said they finally made
his way out somehow those with an empty
low but great defense for atashi back
dash does get clipped but no more any
gauge yeah but he almost has a meter now
how is he going to spend this meter yep
he's got a brc back interesting oh okay
got the hint he's still in this he can
actually take this but it's so scary
opposed sandwich oh and good stuff from
hotashi right there exposing the gap you
got to be super on point to make sure
that gap right there and the sandwich
pressure doesn't get thrown so hitachi
risks it and it pays off now he's on
tournament point two frame throws man
it's it's not one frame oh right there
look at this guess what half of your
life gone in more than half of your life
yeah just like that and the burst is off
the table as well he ended up beating
the burst to get to this point so
jonathan he's really got to run the
one-shot style of the game here you
can't let it hotashi play again he's
just trying to drain him
but hitachi is not using the faultless
defense he's willing to take the chip
because he doesn't care he's got all
this meter to prc
and now jonathan immediately ready with
the 2s on the ground here he's trying to
stay alive fighting for every single
morsel that he can get
all right tries to get in there a yrc
tries to chase down the back dash nice
challenge by oh god that five mage
hitting from so far away in the burst
hedgehog on the verge this has a little
bit of life left oh toshi gets the throw
after the fukio forward comes down to it
and three o's in grand final to crown
himself the number one player in north
america for guilty gear strive you know
coming into this tournament i i you know
obviously all the players are so good
and you know he was talking about how
anyone could win it we even talked about
that and you know we started the day
we started the day with him losing today
it's true but three oh three up but
he's like i won regardless
saying that you know
he is the favorite of this tournament
from the beginning is is not a stretch
you know what i mean like like i said
he's been winning so many of the big
events uh out in in north america he's
been such a strong player
and yeah he is basking it in he knows
asking his glory yeah he knows he is 10k
richer right now so that's a good point
he'll get that pretty trophy dude he's
like oh yeah i forgot about that
all right let's go buddy
dudes a lot of these players again the
pride means so much absolutely and the
message that is being sent
by hotashi taking this tournament like
that and it was such a cool way for it
to end in my opinion because you
highlighted how good jonathan was at
stuffing the fukio forward pressure
right and at the end it came down to
hotashi conditioning him enough to
finally get that fukio forward throw in
and they're working out so beautiful
stuff to hotashi
it looks like we are going to go to the
replays let's check out our grand finals
all right look at this and again
jonathan
he in the in the winter side set you
know it did go all the way down to the
final game final round but this time it
just seemed like hitachi had all of the
right reads and was able to take it so
cleanly at this point
one of the things that you know about
hitachi is he's so analytical i remember
we were watching another match it might
have been uh i think it was like video
secrecy versus razzle and like you know
hatasha was just like i know exactly why
real secrecy is losing you know like he
just has this analytical mind for guilty
gear
i mean that on display he was able to
take it called after command throw again
and that was 100 meter too right like he
had to be
good stuff and that was just one of
those things where when you get
overwhelmed so much by a character like
nagori yuki you take that moment of
offense that you get and you think the
world of it right you're like oh finally
i get to play my game but you got to
respect that 100 tension every time
that's what we were talking about
finally conditioning him enough to no
longer check that forward fukio pressure
hotashi stealing it by tossing him in
the trash here he is your champion
hotashi
standing next to this trophy here oh no
bro hold up you get your moment bro
we're going to talk to you real quick
you'll get your momentum you know how it
is
that's mine over eager just go in
it's translating to your real life
personality right into the trophy you
know
no i mean seriously talk to me about
that you know you were talking about how
strong jonathan tenei played and you
know went to the last game last on the
winner's side what changed all of a
sudden on the grand finals uh
it was
respecting
that 10a will
taney knows i like to stand up because
you know how zotto does the jh into the
jd yeah yeah sure or yeah you know the i
know what you're talking about i try to
uh really switch it up respect
uh don't always block high even though
it's it gets me out the easiest
uh i didn't do any any crazy antics
necessarily
uh 1088 a lot of command grabs that
you know really hits the win percentage
when knuckles all up in your face
doing infinite pressure
uh
i mean it's nothing out of the ordinary
it sounds to me like a straight play
yeah it's a player adjustments right
it's like should have you knew that you
had to end up blocking a little bit more
of the 5ds the dust and whatnot and the
jump mix up as you mentioned i was
getting in a little too easily on super
jump i think that made a ridiculous
difference and i tried to take advantage
of it in the first set
i just had to adjust the spacing stop
trying you know because if i super jump
over zado the six speed goes the other
way yes and then usually i go for grab
my spacing was off uh
now i uh i just suggested that it worked
out much to my benefit well done well
done my man okay so that's i think
enough of the set do you got any any
words for everybody at home yeah yeah
you know what yes
i'll get scolded but it's worth it
it's worth it
so it's like stand behind
i won
arc rivo north america
but
yeah okay sure i'm the best
but more importantly
the world we've been all been inside for
like two years
what's coming
is much more important
let's look overseas
europe is coming
japan is coming
uae is coming
and
i might be the best in north america
but
i want to prove that we're strong even
on the world stage
so i want to see
latif
t t-y slash
skill
gobo or buddy i want to see everybody
and i think north america is ready
without rollback none of this will be
possible
and it's time for international
competition to take center stage whoa
couldn't have said it better myself baby
well done good speech from the champ
right here but i think we got a little
special guest yeah and speaking of
international we do have a very special
guest here to present you the trophy
directly we have the ceo of arxis
himself kiroka-san
come up here stand right here
and there you go
go ahead and hand him the trophy
[Applause]
kiroko-san for doing great things at
arxis we are seeing so much amazing
stuff from them thank you very much yes
thank you and congrats to hotashi once
again
let's take a look at the bracket real
quick to see how we all got here once
again congrats to hotash you can see
taking in three oh in grand finals
over jonathan tennant after a very close
winner's final say you heard him talk
about the adjustments he made just an
expert veteran fighting game player and
i mean really it showed out over and
over again in the whole tournament yeah
absolutely and so congratulations once
again to hotashi the winner of arc rivo
america 2021 10k richer but uh uh you
can see the results here jonathan
antennae going over to 6 500 not bad i
mean if i could have dude at his age if
i could have won 6 500 i got second
place in tournament i think i got like
30 bucks yeah i was because he got a
sandwich yeah exactly sandwich in a bus
stick
you know i was like so happy but days
with five thousand dollars flash metroid
with twenty five hundred dollars
everybody else including chatu including
peppery splash including excellencer all
getting a thousand dollars on top of
that as well so shout outs to everybody
who participated in america but uh are
we done are we done nah james i know the
tournament's over and all that but you
know it's a little something something
that people have been looking forward to
i'm not sure if we actually get into
that exactly just yet what was that some
other base said something did you hear
that i did not hear oh okay you run it
back by me and get another base yeah uh
indeed okay we are going to get to a
trailer height now oh really okay now
now this is just a single trailer we got
a lot more than that yeah don't don't
leave that watch
and then come back stay tuned let's get
it
[Music]
is
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
definitely june 28th for dnf duel it's
going to be i don't know who that first
edgelord character was but i'm playing
i'm 100
that dude looks so cool the guy with the
blue flames of the sword that's my guy
oh man i mean for those of us who did
have the benefit of trying the dnf dual
beta again shout outs to arxis to you
know the rollback netcode that they've
been putting in there that uh that beta
was amazing
the matches felt really good i had fun
throwing wheels at people
and such but uh june 28th we got a
release date june 28th it feels so good
to know that the game's just on the
horizon as well as you mentioned that's
definitely my type of game i like me
some wild offense all kinds of crazy
stuff so most definitely going to be
looking forward to that dnf duel you
remember how dave says like bb tag
changes a man you know like i i feel
like dnf duo might do some similar ready
yeah but um
i don't know if i'm ready for
more stuff perhaps
do we have more stuff yeah you guys look
we told you don't go anywhere just yet
we have some more information for you
guys are you ready for this
james bring it to me let's go let's go
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
a
hey
[Music]
foreign
foreign
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
if the words kill me
[Music]
testament
[Music]
of all the characters james we got
testament in the building it's like that
i'm getting ptsd from fighting testament
on old gamers like let me tell you
testament is one of those characters
that i wanted to see in strive but i
didn't because i was so scared of them
running a rough shot like they used to
but my goodness do they look so well
animated bro i love the way they look
top to bottom
like oh oh my the elegant grim reapers
here i mean look i tell you right now
you know people who wanted who want
testament back they're going to be happy
but all the people who want testament
back were testament players everybody
else is like oh no everybody just wanted
them in story mode right let's see
animated but no you're going to have to
deal with the testimony you're going to
deal with all those players fiesta men
all you testament players i want to see
you all doing work and strive like if
you were if you hadn't fought testament
in the past like i saw the crow land on
test pictures i'm like not the crow
not the crow please no feathers getting
shot at me but you know and on top of
that we got arc reveal 2022 we're gonna
have both guilty gear strive and dnf
dual be a part of it we got another
story at story expansion bowl coming i
need to know what the hell happened to
foust i don't know what caused that man
to be like that play cross prize all the
way through play season two confirmed
four characters
you know since it's a good day kid okay
is here maybe i could just be like
johnny yeah all right all right i think
we're going to take a quick break let
james do some groveling to try to get
his johnny
in the game but before we do yeah before
we do i just want to say again shout
outs to you know our ark system works
they have been killing it they've been
doing so many good things here you know
and a lot of this i feel like comes from
them listening to the fans listening to
the players remember the first beta was
delay-based netcode what got them to
change was all the uh surveys they took
at frosty faustings at the blast arc
revo and everything they put it in there
they showed the world what good replay
good rollback netcode can be about and
now they're adding the crossplay i was
gonna say right we cried and cried for
rollback we got it and what did
everybody start crying for afterwards
cross play right that's what we all need
that's where we want to be able to play
with the largest base possible play all
of our friends that are on the different
platforms and arxis is giving it to us
baby they listen once again and we are
going to get that cross play no more
separate tournaments for uh ops and
steam we get to all be one now and so
again like honestly great stuff to arc
system works they have been doing
they've been killing it and i'm excited
for all the stuff coming for strive i'm
excited for dnf duel
i can't wait to see what they what the
future brings and i want to give a one
more big shout out to all of our players
and everybody that was a part of the
tournament today right i mean it could
never be what it is without our players
and i always love how much they give it
their all how much they leave it all on
the sticks on the hitbox whatever
peripheral you're playing on you feel me
they leave it all out there and it's
just a joy to get to call such high
level fighting games yeah but uh we're
gonna have one more little fun
exhibition after this so i gotta show
jonathan tenney how to play this matchup
okay okay so if you wanna stick around a
little bit you're gonna watch me wipe
the floor with hotashi when we get back
from this break
oh
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
bringing all your bosses
oh
down
[Music]
[Music]
oh
[Music]
[Music]
a
[Music]
forgive me that's not the artifact
keep crying
[Music]
oh
[Music]
those who dream of heaven
forgive me just help me
[Music]
is
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
uh
um
[Music]
[Music]
and welcome back everyone to the
archival america finals you've seen the
champion crown hautashi has taken home
the trophy the victory and all that
you've seen that testament is on the
horizon you've seen that arc rival 2022
is on the horizon james it was a good
day man yeah excellent day and
your day is about to go bad
i guess i you know it looks like okay
fine you know what i i demanded this
from the production as you can see
hotashi is sitting to the side jonathan
10a he admittedly doesn't play the
matchup that well so i'm going to take
down hotashi myself and if i win i'm
taking the trophy hotashi you got to
hold that side yeah i i think that's
that's that's fair that's fair right is
fair right all right i'm going to sit
here because i just want to gather some
thoughts from hotachi here so there's
only i mean honestly there's only really
one question that i have to ask about
this okay so i want your honest opinion
on this right okay okay
how free is this going to be oh here we
go james let me let me tell you about
resolutions
when you make a resolution
the most effective way to get it through
and
really make a change is that you don't
tell anybody oh because if you slip up
on your resolution then everybody's
going to be like nah you you'll be okay
you'll be okay bro
oops trying to aim for amount of
perfects on me or what bro huh
i had a resolution that
in the
for arc revo i would not
purposefully blood rage oh
interesting
and now
i made it through
and oh no my resolution oh no
and it's
it's time to eat some ice cream
so i'm going to show you what naga ryuki
is capable of going all in
oh
let's do this so we're going to get a
little exhibition match here of course
just for your guys entertainment oh yeah
not for my well-being that's for sure
but again shout outs to rinj for sitting
down here to play some matches over here
show you guys what he's got as you know
with his own zotto you know
quick little run back of grand finals
real quick you know it's gonna be it's
gonna be a three out of five again yeah
so official turn i don't gotta i don't
gotta win two sets either to take on the
trophy i only gotta win one i mean if
range wins i mean like you know i think
the trophy i think the prize money
that's a good point james he's like that
final secret boss right you know you
know it's only normal everybody loses
all right here we go oh no
starting already with the pressure
wrench hitting buttons going with those
bro you can't throw me when i oppose
that's cheating
hold that he says and look at this here
we go yeah
bruh that's cheating we agreed
beforehand during the break that you
can't throw me during a pose so that's
one perfect right now
i mean that's why they call it the smell
of the game
i don't like the smell at all
oh i know perfect this time
buddy oh you still popped me i thought i
was going to be able to recover bro
see you later
why would you swing with 2s right there
bro what are you going to do poke me
back i will yeah i wanted to i don't i
ain't i ain't need 60 of my life bar
anyways
i guess that's a good point
oh yeah okay hold up hold up oh oh
you're just gonna eat the drills like
that bro
i should have done five h right there
uh-oh
ah we ain't over bro
come on bro
no no no no
yes oh why did i not pay attention bro
he even told me
sometimes the clock is it's right twice
a day don't you ever heard that one
i have heard that one the only thing
broken here is otto baby let's go
yeah
oh oh i tried to throw you i missed the
button it's not my stick
keep on seven ain't got to pose no
problem man you're gonna keep swinging
into it
oh yeah no i got i got the tight strings
bro i'm not jonathan tennant chill chill
chill you can't throw right there chill
chill chill for me bro i'm chilling
about
oh give me that though
oh
wait a minute
the trophy
come home to me baby see
anybody can do it
you know that 2d was smart though it
didn't work but it was smart
not really i guess i guess nobody
there is no smart option
excuse me
sorry i messed up
you know i don't know you know it was
because you have to do no heroic gene no
it was actually because i was thinking
about cursing
i actually forgot i was like you know i
probably should have burst here but i
just messed up cool
if he had a best friend would you shoot
him across the stage to his desk
if that's what he wanted
[Music]
don't worry brother oh yeah i knew you
were coming for that bro
i knew that much
right every time son
all right i messed up but you see the
frame track be working though yeah
uh-huh they're friends victory
you better download some combos from
twitter man
for real i'm not hitting nothing right
now you better watch latif stream real
quick
get in my dms bro
send me the spreadsheet
oh you're just gonna do that for no
reason oh oh you jumped that was smart
that's why jonathan 2k is your ass every
time bro
[Music]
you can't teabag before throwing i was
trying to jump when you t-bag
my reactions ain't that good bro
oh no i don't want to end on a person
oh i ain't even noticed oh okay that's
alright moral victory am i dead all
right moral victory no perfect
that's why we keep resolutions
all right
i don't wanna i don't wanna do that to
anybody the air horse did i just hear
air
unnecessary roughness please 15 yards on
the field i think
well okay you know what i mean rin's got
one more game than i was expecting him
too that's what i'm saying bro i didn't
get three old he's he's got the power up
because of the fit you know that's fast
there you go but again congratulations
satoshi great job all weekend long
i'm sure you're super excited about
you know the the season and everything
let's go let's go let's go let's head
back over here bro center stage
yeah
again hotashi the
perhaps undisputed best of north for
now congratulations once again your
official trophy here you're now 10k
richer any idea what you're going to do
with that prize money move out of miami
oh
dang just like that woman screw ted cruz
oh my goodness hotashi coming through
the champion he already knows what he's
going to do when he cashes the check as
well thank you all for tuning in
yes thank you all for tuning in again
for our rebel america finals once again
carrasco hitachi thank you so much to
everybody that was a part of the
tournament the production staff the
players james everybody at home watching
viewing just an extra shout out once
again say jazz i hope you're doing well
i hope you get you hope you're feeling
better soon and uh again you know
i hope i hope i covered his issues well
enough definitely most definitely always
salute the general roll back yeah we'll
see y'all soon be good to each other be
good to yourselves until next time
[Music]
i can't believe
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
i don't care how
[Music]
to follow
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
again
is
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
i want to follow
[Music]
[Music]
is
[Music]
we have arrived at grand finals you can
see one of our participants sitting down
the other will join him momentarily
thank you all for sticking with us here
at the park rebel america finals it has
been a long journey we are arriving at
grand finals now hotashi vs jonathan
teddy hotashi put him in loser's bracket
jonathan earned his way back for the run
back and it's going to be a hell of a
grand finals yeah again i mean it was
down to last game last round i think it
was on the winner's side over there now
obviously this is going to be tough
because jonathan tenei needs to actually
win two sets he's in the loser side of
the bracket and hotashi's chilling on
the winner's side so you have to be sent
to losers to be eliminated jonathan 10a
needs to win three out of five and then
another three out of five to take this
tournament absolutely and i just want to
give a shout out to all my zotto players
out there because zato is in grand
finals of every single one of the finals
that's what i'm talking about
in asia finals in the emea finals and
now jonathan 10a completes the trifecta
well done
us potemkin players are just gonna sit
here james when we start playing get to
you you told me you picked bike in the
counter pixato i don't feel sorry for
you bro okay but that's fair that's her
but she's not quite the same yeah it
doesn't work like that anymore
exactly oh i know zotto players hated
that one not as much as jacko and exert
probably but still you know
but yeah look at jonathan he's been
running a mug showing how great xalto is
as a character i really doing a good job
managing his resources effectively
picking the spots that the character
excels best at utilizing those five h's
and those six p's the war criminal
buttons right there he just knows what's
up man yeah exactly and you know hitachi
was saying it best that jonathan tenet
has just been playing like out of his
mind playing very well you know even off
camera he's just been saying he had
nothing but kind things to say about
jonathan's play here uh this weekend and
you know
like i said i i have the pleasure of
being able to see him almost every week
at series e and man he's so good and and
it wasn't even just like he showed up at
series e and was one of the men like he
was obviously good but he's you can see
it's just getting better and better and
better every week
yeah it's really dope to
see him just grow as a fighting game
player continuously same thing with
hotashi right obviously hitachi came a
little bit before his time but we've
watched him grow up in the fight game
community before our eyes and again
doing amazing things like this on the
nagoroyuki keeping it a buck too like
why are you successful in this game he's
like i picked the right character but at
the end of the day right we talked about
it carried by by nagoro right i mean
that's what it is but he mentioned right
he's like i want to make sure that when
people see the character they know it's
me and he has accomplished that 100 like
i said he was one of the sides of that
two-sided coin to developing the gory
yuki's meta in the first place along
with fame so yeah he's done a great job
i think jonathan as well has kind of
innovated a little bit i think he's a
pioneer when it comes to our scene for
whiff punishers and whatnot i see him do
it more than almost any other player so
yeah i think he's quite good now
jonathan was hard on himself in this
matchup right he said i actually think
zotto is better in this matchup than i
make it look right specifically and i
honestly agree with him yeah i do think
he's a little reckless in the matchup
sometimes i think he kind of spins his
rc a little bit too willy-nilly to try
to cover these whiffs that are not
completely him in danger yeah so it'll
be interesting right obviously he's in
grand finals he's done a tremendous job
and things have worked out when he
always just prioritizes keeping as much
control as possible that's why he
already sees those with yes right is to
make sure that at any moment hotashi
cannot take advantage of that opening
yeah but here we are this is it the
grand finals here who's going home with
ten thousand dollars
is it gonna be hotashi or jonathan tenei
it's gonna be nago versus uh zato as
expected
yes most definitely completing the holy
trinity of grand finals in our arc
wrestle series i'm loving it most
definitely and let these intros rock
because this is indeed grand finals we
kicking it off
get it let's
go
and once
again
shout outs to all the players like i i
definitely want to give a shout out to
all six players who are here this
weekend all very good but these are the
two that's left here we go starting off
right away jonathan janae backing off
trying to build some uh some space so we
can get the zato so we can get the eddy
going and gets a burst out of hitachi
right away okay if you're just joining
us watashi is in winter size grand
finals so jonathan has to be in the
whole set to get that first place oh and
that's the thing that we were talking
about right when jonathan doesn't have
the rc meter of his own a lot of time he
just falls back down to the ground
opening him up for throws nice block on
the dust that's something jonathan
highlighted about hitachi coming into
this event how good he is
and you know it's crazy because we've
often complimented jonathan's defense
yeah and then he's sitting here saying
oh my goodness
this is ridiculous but he did get open
up here and he's going to be able to get
the sword so he's going to have another
eddie guaranteed and he's got another
meter as well so he can either use it
yeah there it is i was about to say he
could use it to continue this pressure
for the empty low okay but this is
dangerous if he gets the wall break here
otashi has all that meat expect the brc
there it is it does go forward but
jonathan just blocked it out actually
jumps to command through as well living
for a little while very close to popping
and that 5h does not save him jonathan
weathering the store oh
boy
again
really smart from jonathan to be keeping
track of that blood gauge as you know as
much as hotashi is and i really love
hitachi going to that command grab right
there right we talked about jonathan's
willingness to block it out so he gets a
command through after the first baby
all right here we go towards the corner
position gets the knock down here we go
the meaty invite hell
trying to close that distance get the
plus frames going that's why why rc came
out real quick yeah i think the meter to
keep the pressure going in the corner
with the yeah with the yrc
here we go
far away and eddie got hit prc to save
himself and he's going to be able to
beat the 5h too far away from the first
the catch yeah the sword just doesn't
have a her box like that just completely
whips and now he's gonna be running amok
over aggression and then one more
command pro to do it the quick rc into
the s as well all right one round a
piece jonathan tenei looking really
strong in the first round but here comes
hotashi getting the momentum and getting
the half damage again that's the half
damage starter right there smells deadly
glass half full half empty it doesn't
matter it's half something yeah
it's all discouraging
oh man
when they're harassing me with the 5k
though oh and invading the burst that
with the breaking the loss
with the jump attack
yeah unfortunate hotashi he knows i can
spin all the blood because he's going to
die right there well done 1-0 what a
star for moisture's own
you're not moist enough over there where
are you going to set up
i'm i have no comment i'm going to let
john i'm going to let hitachi
speak for themselves but again two
games now away from 10 000
and cementing himself another big major
win
in the past year great recognition with
jonathan right there canceling appears
into another appearance once he saw the
airborne hit
oh we tried to press something they got
command thrown
all right so here we go yeah and you see
like that whiff of the close slash
that's hitachi trying to make you think
he's vulnerable that's why he whips and
then immediately close slashes and
when the prc covering the whip you want
to get intimate that's my type of game
right there the bite out of crime
hotashi still rocking and rolling
oh
the half damage starts again you like
that you know because how many do you
lose but honestly it's not that bad for
zanto because at least you get back to
mid-screen but now you're in the corner
once again took a bite that means the
blood's draining he's got 100 tension as
well you got to watch out for our
reversal super he's the input i can hear
it so now he's going to go for another
sword super perhaps no he's saving the
meter tries to go for the commando
missed it went for another one but oh
she said no
you know remember how it ended last
night what's he said i can't believe you
went for that command throw
and he called it out again hotashi
back-to-back reads and look at this two
zero potashi
he's taking a swig of his drink here
without having accidentally sacrificing
himself otashi
one game away from
becoming the arc revo america champion
big office right now the
look at that already has jonathan teddy
in the corner once again putting out
those close strings with the cloning
sneaking in the command grab he's just
doing such a good job switching up his
usual offensive rhythm jonathan cannot
play defense
yeah and again you know
there was a lot of modesty when hotashi
was talking about
who was the best in n.a but right now
hitachi is showing
a lot of players something here he is
gonna prc keep the pressure that close
slash is so good because it catches
people trying to jump away as well
cameron just brings you right back to
the ground jonathan said they finally
made his way out somehow this is an
empty lobe of great divas for atashi
back dash does get clipped but no more
any gauge yeah but he almost has a meter
now how is he going to spend this meter
yep he's gonna brc back interesting oh
okay got the hit he's still in this he
can actually take this but it's so scary
opposed sandwich oh and good stuff from
hotashi right there exposing the gap you
got to be super on point to make sure
that gap right there and the sandwich
pressure doesn't get thrown so hitachi
risks it and it pays off now he's on
tournament point two frame throws man
it's it's not one frame right there look
at this guess what half of your life
gone in more than half of your life yeah
just like that and the burst is off the
table as well he ended up beating the
burst to get to this point so john then
he's really got to run the one-shot
style of the game here you can't let
hitachi play again he's just trying to
drain
his meter but hitachi is not using the
faultless defense he's willing to take
the chip because he doesn't care he's
got all this meter to prc what attack
and jonathan immediately ready with the
2s on the ground here he's trying to
stay alive fighting for every single
morsel that he can get
all right tries to get in there a yrc
tries to chase down the back dash nice
challenge by oh god that 5 8 hitting
from so far away in the burst
and jonathan on the verge this has a
little bit of life left oh tashi gets
the throw after the fukio forward comes
down to it and three o's in grand final
to crown himself the number one player
in north america for guilty gear strive
you know coming into this tournament i i
you know obviously all the players are
so good and you know he was talking
about how anyone could win it we even
talked about that and you know we
started the day
we started the day with him losing
today's true
regardless
saying that you know
he is the favorite of this tournament
from the beginning is is not a stretch
you know what i mean like like i said
he's been winning so many of the big
events uh out in in north america he's
been such a strong player
and yeah he is basking it in he knows
asking his glory yeah he knows he is 10k
richard right now so that's a good point
and he'll get that pretty trophy
he's like oh yeah i forgot about that
right let's go
little quick racks
a lot of these players again the pride
means so much
and the message that is being sent by
hotashi taking this tournament like that
and it was such a cool way for it to end
in my opinion because you highlighted
how good jonathan was at stuffing the
fukio forward pressure right and at the
end it came down to hotashi conditioning
him enough to finally get that fukio
forward throw in and it working out so
beautiful stuff to hotashi
it looks like we are gonna go to the
replays let's check out our grand finals
all right look at this and again
jonathan
he in the in the winner's side set you
know it did go all the way down to the
final game final round but this time it
just seemed like hitachi had all of the
right reads and was able to take it so
cleanly at this point
yes
one of the things that you know about
hitachi is he's so analytical i remember
we were watching another match it might
have been uh i think it was like
idiosyncrasy versus razzle and like you
know hatashi was just like i know
exactly why real secrecy is losing you
know like he just has this analytical
mind for guilty gear
i mean that on display he was able to
take it called after command throw again
and now that was 100 meter too right
like you had to be careful so good stuff
and that was just one of those things
where when you get overwhelmed so much
by a character like nagori yuki you take
that moment of offense that you get and
you think the world of it right you're
like oh finally i get to play my game
but you got to respect that 100 tension
every time that's what we were talking
about finally conditioning him enough to
no longer check that forward fukio
pressure hotah she's stealing it by
tossing him in the trash
here he is your champion hotashi
standing next to this trophy here oh no
bro hold up you get your moment bro we
gotta talk to you real quick
you'll get your momentum you know how it
is
that's mine over eager just go in
it's translating to your real life
personality right
to the trophy you know
no i mean seriously talk to me about
that you know you were talking about how
strong jonathan tenei played and you
know went to the last game last round on
the winner's side what changed all of a
sudden on the grand finals uh
it was
respecting
that 10a will
taney knows i like to stand up because
you know how zotto does the jh into the
jd yeah yeah sure or yeah you know the
myths i know what you're talking about i
try to uh really switch it up respect
uh don't always block high even though
it gets me out the easiest
i didn't do any any crazy antics
necessarily
uh tennant ate a lot of command grabs
that
you know really hits the wind percentage
when noggles all up in your face
doing infinite pressure
uh
i mean it's nothing out of the ordinary
it sounds to me like just straight play
yeah it's a player adjustments right
it's like should have you knew that you
had to end up blocking a little bit more
of the 5ds the dust and whatnot and the
jump mix as you mentioned i was getting
in a little too easily on super jump i
think that made a ridiculous difference
and i tried to take advantage of it in
the first set i just had to adjust the
spacing stop trying you know because if
i super jump over zado the six speed
goes the other way yes and then usually
i go for grab my spacing was off uh
now i uh i just suggested that it worked
out much to my benefit well done well
done my man okay so that's i think
enough of the set do you got any any
words for everybody at home yeah mia
you know what yes
i'll get scolded but it's worth it
it's worth it
so it's like stand behind
i won
arc rival north america
but
yeah okay sure i'm the best
but more importantly
the world we've been all been inside for
like two years
what's coming
is much more important
let's look overseas
europe is coming japan is coming
uae is coming
and
i might be the best in north america
but
i want to prove that we're strong even
on the world stage
so i want to see
latif
t y slash
skill
gobo or buddy i want to see everybody
and i think north america is ready
without rollback none of this will be
possible
and it's time for international
competition to take center stage whoa
couldn't have said it better myself baby
well done good speech from the champ
right here but i think we got a little
special good yeah and speaking of
international we do have a very special
guest here to present you the trophy
directly we have the ceo of arxis
himself kiroka-san
come up here stand right here
you and there you go
go ahead and hand him the trophy
[Laughter]
and shout out here let me get that up
bro let me get that up
and also definitely shout out to hotashi
shout outs to mr kiroko-san for doing
great things at arxis we are seeing so
much amazing stuff from them thank you
very much yes thank you and congrats to
hotashi once again let's take a look at
the bracket real quick to see how we all
got here once again congrats to hotash
you can see taking it three owen grand
finals
over jonathan tonight after a very close
winners final say you heard him talk
about the adjustments he made just an
expert veteran fighting game player and
i mean really it showed out over and
over again in the whole tournament yeah
absolutely and so congratulations once
again to hotashi the winner of arc revo
america 2021 10k richer but uh uh you
you can see the results here jonathan
antennae going over to 6500 not bad i
mean if i could have dude at his age
i could have won 6 500 i got second
place in tournament i think i got like
30 bucks
because he got a sandwich yeah exactly
sandwich in a bus stick at home like i
think i ate like a red robin afterwards
you know i was like so happy but days
with five thousand dollars flash metroid
with 2500
everybody else including chatu including
peppery splash including ex-lancer all
getting a thousand dollars on top of
that as well so shout outs to everybody
who participated in america but uh are
we done are we are we done yeah james i
know the tournament's over and all that
but you know it's a little something
something that people have been looking
forward to i'm not sure if we're
actually getting to that exactly just
yet what was that some other base said
something did you hear that i did not
hear oh okay are you running back by me
and getting another base yeah uh ooh
indeed okay we are going to get to a
trailer height in that oh really okay
now now this is just a single trailer we
got a lot more than that yeah don't
don't leave watch this yeah and then
come back stay tuned let's get it
[Music]
is
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
definitely june 28th for dnf duel it's
going to be i don't know who that first
edge lord character was but i'm playing
i'm 100
that dude looks so cool the guy with the
blue flames of the sword that's my guy
oh man i mean for those of us who did
have the benefit of trying the dnf dual
beta again shout outs to arxis to you
know the rollback netcode that they've
been putting in there that uh that beta
was amazing
the matches felt really good i had fun
throwing wheels at people
and such but uh june 28th we got a
release date june 28th it feels so good
to know that that game's just on the
horizon as well as you mentioned that's
definitely my type of game i like me
some wild offense all kinds of crazy
stuff so most definitely going to be
looking forward to that dnf duel you
remember how dave says like bb tag
changes a man you know like i i feel
like dnf duo might do some similar ready
yeah but um
i don't know if i'm ready for
more stuff perhaps
do we have more stuff yeah you guys look
we told you don't go anywhere just yet
we have some more information for you
guys are you ready for this
james bring it to me let's go let's go
be
[Music]
[Music]
is
[Music]
[Music]
is
me
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
yes
[Music]
how
[Music]
to see i'm blazing still my heart is
blazing if the words kill me
[Music]
[Music]
uh
bye
of all the characters james we got
testament in the building it's like that
i'm getting ptsd from fighting testament
on old games like let me tell you
testament is one of those characters
that i wanted to see in strive but i
didn't because i was so scared of them
running a rough shot like they used to
but my goodness do they look so well
animated bro i love the way they look
top to bottom
i mean look i tell you right now you
know people who wanted who want
testament back they're going to be happy
but all the people who want testament
back were testament players everybody
else is like oh no everybody just wanted
them in story mode right like let's see
animated but no you're going to have to
deal with the testament you get to deal
with all those players fiesta men all
you testament players i want to see you
all doing work and stride like if you
were if you hadn't fought testament in
the past like i saw the crow land on
test pictures i'm like not the crow
not the crow please no feathers getting
shot at me but you know and on top of
that we got arc reveal 2022 we're gonna
have both guilty gear strive and and f
dual be a part of it we got another
story a story expansionable coming i
need to know what the hell happened to
foust i don't know what caused that man
to be like that play cross prize all the
way through play season two confirmed
four characters
you know since it's a good thing kid
okay is here maybe i could just be like
johnny
yeah all right all right i think we're
gonna take a quick break let james do
some groveling to try to get his johnny
in the game but before we do yeah before
we do i just want to say again shout
outs to you know our ark system works
they have been killing and they've been
doing so many good things here you know
and a lot of this i feel like comes from
them listening to the fans listening to
the players remember the first beta was
delay based net code what got them to
change was all the uh surveys they took
at frosty faustings at the last arc revo
and everything they put it in there they
showed the world what good net play good
rollback netcode can be about and now
they're adding the crossplay i was gonna
say right we cried and cried for
rollback we got it and what did
everybody start crying for afterwards
crossplay right that's what we all need
that's where we want to be able to play
with the largest base possible play all
of our friends that are on the different
platforms and arxis has given it to us
baby they listen once again and we are
going to get that crossplay no more
separate tournaments for uh ops and
steam we get to all be one now and so
again like honestly great stuff to arc
system works they have been doing
they've been killing it and i'm excited
for all the stuff coming for strive i'm
excited for dnf duel
i can't wait to see what they what the
future brings and i want to give a one
more big shout out to all of our players
and everybody that was a part of the
tournament today right i mean it could
never be what it is without our players
and i always love how much they give it
their all how much they leave it all on
the sticks on the hitbox whatever
peripheral you're playing on you feel me
they leave it all out there and it's
just a joy to get to call such high
level fighting games yeah but uh we're
gonna have one more little fun
exhibition after this so i gotta show
jonathan tennant how to play this
matchup
okay okay so if you want to stick around
a little bit you're going to watch me
wipe the floor with hotashi when we get
back from this break
[Music]
uh
[Music]
tell me
you